y a-t-il des observations
je me vois pas le procès-verbal est donc
adopté sur les réserves d'usage l'ordre
du jour
l'examen des crédits de la mission
défense et article 42 du projet de loi
de finances
et dans cet examen la parole d'abord à
Monsieur Dominique dellèle rapporteur de
la commission des finances
sur le président sur le ministre chers
collègues les crédits de la mission
défense s'élève à 62 milliards d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement et 5300
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
sans compter les pensions et à périmètre
courant les CP progresse donc de 3
milliards d'euros pour s'établir à 44
milliards ainsi la stricte point de vue
budgétaire la LPM aura été respectée
chaque année depuis 2019 ce dont nous
nous félicitons cependant si elle est
respectée d'un strict au point de vue
budgétaire et ne l'est pas d'un point de
vue capacitaire pour trois raisons la
première le prélèvement de 24 à
sur la dotation de l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace pour les besoins d'un export
au profit de la Grèce et de la Croatie
constitue une profonde remise en cause
de l'objectif fixé par la LPM à
l'horizon de 2025 pour la flotte de
Rafale sans compter que cette ponction
de près de 20 % du parc non seulement
des conséquences sur le plan
opérationnel mais affecte durablement la
formation du pilote de chasse dont le
nombre annuel d'heures de vol passerait
de 162 à 147 en 2023 loin de l'objectif
fixé deuxième raison la fourniture de 18
annonces César aux forces armées
ukrainiennes en plus les moyens de
l'armée de terre de près d'un quart de
son parc enfin l'actualisation
stratégique décidé en 2021 au mépris du
respect de la LPM et du Parlement a eu
pour conséquence de remettre en cause et
l'exécution et le calendrier de
plusieurs programmes pour un montant que
nous estimons à plus de 3 milliards
d'euros et que nos collègues de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la Défense et des forces
évalue après de 8 milliards il ne s'agit
donc pas tout à fait de l'épaisseur du
trait ainsi les commandes de
recomplètement de notre flotte de Rafale
s'élève à plus de 2 milliards et demi
d'euros et celle du parc de canon César
après 80 millions qui vont être financés
souvent enveloppes LPM affectant
d'autant son exécution dans l'attente de
la prochaine programmation annoncée par
le Premier ministre dès l'année
prochaine cette année nos armées ont été
mobilisées sur le flanc Est de l'Europe
et dans le cadre des missions de
réassurance de l'Organisation du Traité
de l'Atlantique à ce titre la France
intervient notamment comme nationca de
la mission aigle en Roumanie le surcoût
de cette projection de nos armées
s'élève après de 700 millions d'euros en
2022 et il est déjà estimé environ 250
millions d'euros en 2023 il a fait
l'objet d'un financement grâce à
l'ouverture de crédit dans le cadre de
la loi de finance rectificative en fin
de gestion cependant comme les années
précédentes les surcoulis aux opérations
extérieures liées notamment à la
réarticulation en cours du dispositif
d'arcane au Sahel ont été financés par
des redéploiements internes à l'émission
sous enveloppes LPM contrairement aux
dispositions de son article 4 c'est sur
court représente près de 400 millions
d'euros
au-delà de ces éléments de contexte
plusieurs points d'attention méritent
d'être soulignés pour l'exercice qui
s'ouvre premièrement l'impact de
l'inflation sur le budget désormais
évalué un milliard d'euros afin que cet
impact ne conduisent pas absorber les
tiers de l'augmentation des crédits le
gouvernement a fait le choix de le
financer par report de charge sur
l'année 2024
privilégiant ainsi la fichage d'un reste
des strict de la marche prévue par la
LPM plutôt que le reflet fidèle des
besoins des armées cette méthode qui
revient à créer de la dette dans la
dette me paraît constitutive d'une forme
d'incées
de plus à l'heure où le gouvernement
parle d'économie de guerre et attend une
réactivité accrue de la part des
industriels pour accélérer les
livraisons indispensables au
renouvellement des matériels il paraît
mal venu de laisser entrevoir un
paiement différé des livraisons paiement
générateur lui-même d'agios la raison
des retards
deuxième point des efforts importants
ont été consentis ces dernières années
en matière de conditions opérationnelles
notamment grâce à la conclusion avec les
industriels de larges contrat
verticalisés dont il conviendra
d'évaluer l'efficacité pour autant la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
des équipements des trois armées restent
globalement en deçà des objectifs avec
un point de vigilance qui perdure
s'agissant des hélicoptères de l'armée
de terre troisième point notre retrait
du Sahel et notre soutien à l'Ukraine
modifiera certainement nos projections
avec une baisse des OPEX au sens
financier du terme et une
restructuration de notre mobilisation
sur le front
ukrainien je ne doute pas que nos
collègues de la commission de la défense
développeront ce point
mais surtout quatrième élément sur
lequel je souhaite
intervenir cette année budgétaire sera
l'heure de vérité pour l'avenir de nos
armées au-delà de notre et au-delà pour
notre souveraineté nationale je veux
parler du système de combat aérien du
futur Scaff lancé en 2017 ce projet
conditionne l'avenir de notre armée
notre place en Europe et notre place au
sein de l'OTAN chaque jour de retard
supplémentaire dans la conduite de ce
projet est un jour perdu pour la
préparation des armées françaises à la
guerre aérienne du futur alors même que
les besoins opérationnels ont été
exprimés avec la plus grande clarté par
nos chefs d'état-major le projet
consiste à rassembler et connecter des
moyens de combat autour d'un nouvel
avion de chasse polyvalent et en ayant
recours à l'intelligence artificielle ce
futur avion devra aussi répondre aux
exigences opérationnelles françaises
puisqu'il devra assurer des composantes
aéroportés de la dissuasion nucléaire et
être n'avalysable c'est à dire on mesure
de pouvoir apporter sur le nouveau
porte-avions toutefois les négociants
ont pris un sérieux retard même si
l'accord entre les industriels devant
fixer le cahier des charges du nouvel
avion en vue du lancement de la phase de
démonstration prévue l'an prochain a été
enfin signé il ne s'agit toutefois que
d'une première étape dans un chemin qui
semble encore semé d'embûches dans ce
contexte on ne peut plus tout à fait
exclure qu'il fallait réfléchir à une
alternative nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir lors du débat sur un amendement
que nous avons disposé pour entendre
plus clairement les intentions du
Gouvernement et sa vision des choses je
vous remercie
merci cher collègue et maintenant nous
allons entendre les 8 rapports pour avis
de la commission des affaires étrangères
commençons par Monsieur Pascal Alizard
chacun étant doté d'une provision de 3
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2023 les
crédits du programme 144 s'élèveront
après de 2 milliards d'euros en crédit
de paiement en matière d'innovation
l'enveloppe consacrée aux études amont
atteindra le milliard d'euros ce qui est
conforme aux engagements nous vous en
donnons acte monsieur le ministre ces
crédits importants permettront notamment
le financement des études relatives au
successeur du char Leclerc et au système
de combat aérien du futur ainsi que la
poursuite des études sur les thématiques
telles que la lutte antidrone l'hyper
vélocité et la quantique si les
priorités retenus les moyens inscrits
dans le présent PLF nous semble aller
dans le bon sens nous constatons que
l'agence de l'innovation de défense n'a
plus de directeur de plein exercice
depuis près de six mois ce ministre il
nous semble que le message n'est pas bon
alors que le rôle de l'aide est
absolument fondamental et nous appelons
donc à nommer un directeur à sa tête
dans les plus brefs délais par ailleurs
s'agissant du SCAF l'accord sur le
démarrage de la phase 1 B confirmé la
semaine dernière par Dassault est
évidemment bienvenu mais mérite d'être
suivi avec vigilance nous souhaitons que
le gouvernement fasse preuve de la plus
grande transparence sur ce dossier
au-delà de la question des moyens
consacrés à l'innovation plusieurs défis
doivent être relevés par l'ID et la
Direction Générale pour l'Armement
premier lieu l'accélération de la montée
en maturité des technologies nous
proposons que le rôle crucial des
démonstrateurs soit renforcés avec la
réalisation d'un prototype à un stade
assez précoce pour permettre aux
opérationnels de proposer les incréments
nécessaires en second lieu le conflit
ukrainien rappelé l'absolu nécessité de
retrouver de la masse il s'agit de
prendre en compte cette exigence au
stade des études amont par exemple en
envisageant dès le départ deux versions
la même technologie une version de haute
technologie permettant l'entrée en
premier et une version moins
sophistiquée mais pouvant être produite
en plus grande quantité permettant un
volume d'attrition plus important et
dont l'exportation serait facilitée j'en
viens à la question du financement de
notre pays TD le passage et une économie
de guerre nous semble nécessiter
aujourd'hui plus qui hier de garantir
l'accès aux sources de financement des
entreprises de la défense si les
discours tenus sur cette question sont
contradictoires nous considérons pour
notre part qu'il existe bien des cas de
refus de financement du fait de
l'appartenance au secteur de la défense
en outre les projets de taxonomie ou
encore de monter en puissance des normes
ESG constitue autant de risques pour nos
entreprises nos alertes répétées ont
permis de sensibiliser jusqu'au sommet
de l'État sur cette problématique nous
nous en félicitons pour autant en la
matière la vigilance reste de mise mes
chers collègues sous le bénéfice des
observation et de ces observations et de
celles qui vont vous être présentées par
Yannick vogrenard en l'occurrence ce
sera moi-même dans quelques instants la
Commission avait mis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits du programme 144
je vous remercie cher collègue vous
poursuivez au nom de Yannick beaugrenard
et monsieur le président
monsieur le Président chers collègue
monsieur le ministre donc effectivement
je prends ici la parole en lieu et place
de mon corps rapporteur Yannick
vogrenard qui est excusé il aurait lui
aussi salué la concordance globale des
crédits du programme 144 pour 2023 avec
la ligne tracée par la loi de
programmation militaire mais il y a des
problèmes qui ne sont pas d'ordre
budgétaire nous partageons avec Yannick
vogrenard le souci du financement de la
BITD notamment au PME et ETI qui ne
disposent pas des mêmes facilités
d'accès au crédit que les grands groupes
nous pensons à la souveraineté
industrielle qui est le vrai sujet de
l'économie de guerre pour le département
de la Loire-Atlantique Yannick Brou
renard vous aurait dit que la
construction du porte-avion de nouvelle
générations se préparent dès maintenant
avec la mobilisation de tous
l'écosystème industriels autour des
Chantiers de l'Atlantique même si la
livraison n'est prévue qu'en 2038 je
pourrais d'ailleurs vous en dire autant
pour la Normandie s'agissant de la
construction des sous-marins de
nouvelles génération j'en viens
maintenant au crédit à louer au service
de renseignement l'année 2023
correspondra pour la DGSE et la DR SD à
une montée en puissance dans le cyber
défense et la modernisation immobilière
de leur siège respectifs la DGSE
s'engage dans une opération de grande
ampleur de déménagement à Vincennes à
l'horizon 2028 elle conduit au sud
importante réforme de son organisation
avec la fusion des fonctions de
recherche et d'opération au sein d'une
même direction la drsd a aussi lancé une
vaste reconfiguration de ces locaux et
de ces systèmes d'information dans ce
contexte de transformation le budget
global de fonctionnement et
d'investissement de la DGSE de la DRST
augmentera de ses ennemis pour cent pour
atteindre près de 476 millions d'euros
en comptant les dépenses de personnel
qui dépendent du programme 212 le
renseignement bénéficiera de plus d'un
virgule un milliard d'euros cette
tendance s'inscrit dans les priorités de
la LPM et qui apparaît justifier au
regard de l'intensification des menaces
conventionnelles mais aussi hybrides
dans les domaines du cyber et de
l'influence c'est pourquoi au moins
trois sujets pose question et devront
être surveillés tout au long de
l'exécution de ce budget 2023 d'abord la
question du recrutement de spécialistes
cyber la réalité du marché de l'emploi
en fait une denrée rare et cher les
services utilisent les réseaux sociaux
pour lancer leur campagne de recrutement
c'est une politique de communication
novatrice a encouragé ensuite le
chiffrage de l'impact budgétaire de la
guerre en Ukraine nécessairement et sans
entrer dans le détail la DGSE comme la
DST opèrent à redéploiement opérationnel
sur le flanc Est de l'OTAN enfin nos
services vont devoir dès 2023 s'investir
dans le champ de la guerre
internationale et de l'influence pour
mettre en oeuvre ce que le président de
la République a désigné comme une
nouvelle fonction stratégique lors de
son discours le 9 novembre 2022 à Toulon
nous y étions ces priorités sont
nouvelles s'imposent à nous il faudra
donc les prendre en compte dans la
prochaine LPM à cet égard je vous
annonce que je conduirai avec mon corps
à porteur nous conduirons ensemble un
groupe de travail spécifique sur le
financement de l'innovation de l'abbé TD
et des services de renseignement pour
conclure monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues au
bénéfice de ces observations Yannick
vogrenard vous propose un avis favorable
sur les crédits du programme 144 je vous
remercie merci chers collègues et
maintenant c'est à Olivier gigolotti
rapporteur pour habiller également de la
Commission
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les présidents de
commissions mes chers collègues les
crédits de paiement du programme 178
augmente de 1,2 milliards d'euros
essentiellement pour financer l'effort
en faveur de l'entretien programmé du
matériel nécessaire au regard des
résultats en berne en termes de
disponibilités techniques opérationnelle
en effet
71% des indicateurs sont en stagnation
ou en diminution en 2023 pour l'armée de
terre 5 des 7 indicateurs régresses ceux
des hélicoptères du Charles clair des
vbrc avec le retard de livraison des
jaguars et enfin des Césars en raison de
la session de 18 canons aux forces
armées ukrainiennes pour la Marine
Nationale 3 des 7 indicateurs reculent
notamment ceux de la chasse et des
hélicoptères à cause du passage au
standard F4 du Rafale et de la corrosion
des caïmans pour l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace les difficultés tiennent tous
exportations des rafales
en 2023 les crédits consacrés à l'EPM
s'élèveront à 5,5 milliards d'euros ce
qui correspond à l'addition de la nuité
prévue par la LPN sur 4,4 milliards
d'euros et des 900 millions d'euros
manquants faute d'inscription à LFI
depuis le début de la période de
programmation et pourtant ce n'est pas
satisfaisant puisque ce montant de
crédit ne rattrape pas les retards mais
finances 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires destinés aux munitions
les leçons tirées de la guerre en
Ukraine s'imposent en la matière mais
cela signifie qu'une fois de plus les
crédits de PM financent des besoins non
prévus par la LPM
2019-2025 au détriment des besoins
initialement retenus
nous devons nous devons donc être très
attentifs à la pleine satisfaction des
besoins en EPM dans la prochaine période
de programmation nous savons déjà que
ces besoins sont importants et sous
dotés dans l'actuel loi de programmation
pour l'entretien des nouvelles
infrastructures et des nouveaux
équipements livrés aux armées mais aussi
pour le démantèlement des flots
d'aéronef en déflation et des navires
retirés du service actif leur stockage
faute de démantèlement ne peut être vu
comme une solution satisfaisante il
faudra également prendre en compte
l'adaptation du service interarmée des
munitions à l'hypothèse d'engagement
majeur en le dotant des 80 personnels
militaires supplémentaires nécessaires
en augmentant et à modernisant sa
capacité de stockage et en organisant de
nouveaux modes de mise à disposition des
munitions notamment par acheminement
ferroviaire
nous approfondirons dans le cadre de nos
travaux de préparation de la prochaine
LPM ses premières réflexions sur les
munitions avec d'autant plus
d'efficacité monsieur le ministre que
vous ne manquerez pas de recommander au
service de nous faciliter la tâche mes
chers collègues sous réserve de ces
observations la commission adopter les
crédits du programme 178 de la mission
des forces
et maintenant la parole est à Madame
Michel Gréau me rapporte pour avis de la
commission
et toujours pour 3 minutes
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues la hausse des
crédits du programme 178 ne permet
toujours pas la remontée de l'activité
opérationnelle des forces et de
l'entraînement qui reste inférieur aux
objectifs fixés de près de 10%. en 2023
la situation se détériore pour trois
quarts des indicateurs d'activité cela
se traduit par une diminution de la
capacité de deux des trois armées à
honorer leur contrat opérationnel
depuis 2017 la préparation
opérationnelle de l'armée de terre
stagne elle doit remonter en 2022 à 82
jours mais pour être de nouveau
fragilisé par la réassurance en Roumanie
de l'OTAN
pour la Marine nationale le retard pris
par le programme des frégats de défense
et d'intervention explique la baisse de
la capacité à honorer le contrat
opérationnel à 70 % pour l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace
l'impact des exportations rafales sur
lequel notre commission alerté le
gouvernement est désormais tangible des
conséquences la capacité à honorer le
contrat opérationnel chute à 65% en 2023
et ne devrait pas remonter en 2024
le choc stratégique de la guerre en
Ukraine rappelle à quel point
l'entraînement est essentiel nous
devrons obtenir les objectifs chiffrés
de remontée de la préparation
opérationnelle dans la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire il faut éviter
qu'elle soit la variable d'ajustement
inavouée des ambitions non financées de
la LPM il nous faudra veille aussi
veiller sur les services de soutien
aujourd'hui à la peine il ne doivent pas
être de nouveau sacrifier à tous les
autres objectifs de la LPM nous savons
qu'ils soient essentiels et
indispensables dans l'hypothèse un
engagement majeur la guerre en Ukraine a
ainsi rappelé avec ses colonnes de
charrue s'immobiliser faute de
ravitaillement le déficit en médecin du
premier secours de l'ordre de 125 en
2021 et non communiqué pour 2022 et la
surprojection des personnels fragilisent
le service de santé des armées
il ne tiendra l'hypothèse engagement
majeure qu'avec le plan d'appui du
service public de la santé lui-même en
crise sans oublier qu'il est impératif
également de préparer une défense contre
une attaque radiologique biologique et
chimique
la réflexion sur l'économie de guerre ne
peut en aucun cas se dispenser du volet
sanitaire et la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire devra refléter
cette nécessité de même les besoins du
service du commissariat des armées pour
faire face à l'inflation aux nouvelles
normes légales et à la haute intensité
ne doivent pas être négligée et nous et
nous les évaluons déjà au moins 250
millions d'euros pour approfondir notre
travail de recensement des besoins de
des services de soutien il est
indispensable monsieur le ministre que
votre cabinet nous aide à organiser dans
les meilleurs délais les auditions qui
nous permettront d'effectuer notre
travail de préparation de la prochaine
LPM l'urgence en la matière vous est
désormais connu merci
et bien maintenant la parole est un
Monsieur Joël guerriot rapporteur
en son nom et ensuite pour Madame
Carlotti qui est excusé
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
programme 212 soutient de la politique
de défense rassemble comme chaque année
l'ensemble des crédits dédié aux
dépenses de personnel du ministère des
armées qui s'élève à 22,4 milliards pour
l'année 2023
fuite aux annonces importantes faites
cet été nous avons orienté nos travaux
sur la réserve opérationnelle qui est de
financée par les dépenses de personnel
rattachées au programme 212 pour rappel
la réserve opérationnelle de premier
niveau et constitué de citoyens français
volontaires qui signent un engagement à
servir dans la réserve d'une durée
renouvelable de 5 ans
de 1 à 50 une fois intégré alors
organisme de rattachement s'est
réservistes servent sous statut
militaire au sein des forces armées et
formations rattachées je tiens ici à
souligner que ces réservistes
opérationnels jouent un rôle essentiel
dans nos différentes forces on peut
également penser à l'implication très
importante des réservistes de l'armée de
terre dans le cadre de l'opération
sentinelle depuis 2015
cette observation peut également être
déclinée dans les autres forces par
exemple il nous a été indiqué que lors
des déploiements majeurs du travail et
du groupe aéronaval lui porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle l'état-major embarqué
et renforcé par 10 à 20% de réserves
opérationnels de la Marine nationale
actuellement la réserve opérationnelle
des armées est constituée d'environ 40
000 réservistes conformément un objectif
fixé dans la loi de programmation
militaire de l'été 2015 cette cible a
été confirmée dans la loi de
programmation actuelle pour la période
2019-2025 ce format correspond à une
remontée en puissance pour les réserves
des armées qui comptaient encore moins
de 28 000 personnels il y a moins de 10
ans lors de son discours aux armées du
13 juillet dernier le président de la
République a annoncé un objectif de
doublement du volume de la réserve
opérationnelle des armées
ce nouveau format impliquera de très
largement renforcer le rythme de
recrutement des réservistes bien sûr
dans les années à venir selon les
informations qui nous ont été
communiquées le volume de recrutement
annuel devra passer de 4700 à plus de
9000 pour atteindre l'objectif annoncé
la mise en œuvre de cette remontée en
puissance devra être prise en compte sur
le plan budgétaire et pour atteindre les
objectifs de renforcement de la
résilience de notre corps social et de
diffusion d'esprit de défense il faudra
que le temps de service moyen des
réservistes opérationnels soit
préservées c'est à dire que la
trajectoire budgétaire du programme 212
tienne compte de cette ambition nouvelle
alors j'ai déjà gagné un peu de temps et
je vais maintenant prendre la parole
au titre merci
au Trites du rapport qui cette fois-ci
vous est présenté au nom de Madame Marie
Arlette Carlotti ma chère collègue
co-rapporte
nous avons également nous dit-elle
travailler sur la nouvelle politique de
rémunération des militaires l'année 2023
sera marquée par la mise en œuvre
définitive d'une réforme qui porte bien
mal son nom elle se voulait d'ampleur
mais restera le partiel car le choix a
été fait de se concentrer uniquement sur
la part indemnitaire de la rémunération
des militaires avec un double objectif
de simplification et d'équité rappelons
que cette rémunération est composée de
deux parties sur le modèle de la
fonction publique la part indiciaire ou
solde de base qui dépend des grades et
des échelons et la part indemnitaire
composée d'indemnités de primes diverses
les primes indemnités représentent une
part importante de la rémunération des
militaires 30% en moyenne pour les
militaires durant et 44% pour les
officiers généraux
en 2021 avant la réforme la rémunération
des militaires était caractérisée par la
complexité de la composante prime et
indemnités on y comprenait rien il
existait
164 prime différentes c'était donc un
système éligible et nous l'avions
nous-mêmes qualifié d'obsolète
concernant la simplification il faut
souligner le succès de cette réforme en
effet désormais le ministère des armées
aura à gérer le versement de 8 primes
seulement contre plus donc 270
auparavant comme je l'ai indiqué cela en
supprimant les primes obsolètes en
harmonisant les critères d'attribution
en renforçant le caractère universel
comme la prime de mobilité géographique
et en ouvrant les primes aux
célibataires et à toutes les formes
d'union quant à l'équité le système
indemnitaire du ministère des armées
sera-t-il plus équitable il y aura-t-il
des perdants la DRH du ministère de la
Défense nous dit que non mais il est
difficile de répondre clairement à ce
stade aussi nous verrons par exemple
l'absence de mécanismes de
revalorisation automatique va créer nous
le constatons déjà un tassement des
salaires qui sanctionne particulièrement
les officiers car les primes
représentent près de la moitié de la
rémunération
la question de la fiscalisation de
certaines primes sur le revenu des
militaires aura des conséquences
difficiles à évaluer sur le plan
financier
si la nprm est appuyée sur une enveloppe
budgétaire de 70 millions d'euros en
2022 ce montant reste très limité au
regard de l'ensemble des dépenses de
personnels du ministère il représente
moins de 1% de l'ensemble des
rémunérations d'activités versées par le
mystère des armées en 2022 enfin sur la
méthode nous regrettons que les
instances de concertation ont été
associées dans une logique d'information
plus cool que de co-construction au
regard du respect de la trajectoire
fixée par la LPM la Commission a été
émis à émis un avis favorable à
l'adoption de crédit du programme 212
mais nous resterons attentifs à ce que
la question de la condition militaire
soit pleinement prise en compte dans les
travaux à venir sur la prochaine
programmation militaire
merci de votre attention merci chers
collègues et la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Cédric Perrin pour 3 minutes
également
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues les chroniques les
crédits d'équipement des forces
augmentent de 900 millions d'euros
confirmement à LPM mais depuis 2018
évidemment le monde a changé d'abord la
crise du covid le gouvernement alors
considéré que la LPM faisait office de
plan de relance puis avec la guerre
déclenchée par les Russes en Ukraine le
gouvernement iron là encore par une les
LPM constante
il est désormais question de bâtir une
économie de guerre mais encore
faudrait-il commencer par passer
quelques commandes supplémentaires sur
des équipements cruciaux qui ne semblent
pas être le cas puisqu'on nous a
confirmé encore la semaine dernière
qu'aucune commande de munitions
nouvelles n'avait été effectuée depuis
le 24 février dernier peut-être
pourrez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
rassurer sur ce point cette guerre va
vous nous l'expliquerez cette guerre a
entraîné une accélération de l'inflation
et un bouleversement du contexte
géostratégique l'effet de l'inflation
sur le programme 146 est évalué à 460
millions d'euros en 2023 le recours au
report de charge qui représentera 15%
des crédits en 2023 permet de boucler le
budget par un tour de passe-passe c'est
en fait le retour de la bosse budgétaire
au détriment des créanciers du ministère
alors que la LPM encourt devait y
remédier une indexation sur l'inflation
est fondamentalement nécessaire des
mêmes qu'un rehaussement de la provision
pour les opérations extérieures et les
missions intérieures qui se révèlent
chaque année insuffisantes
les surcoûts entraînent encore cette
année une annulation de crédit mise en
réserve sur le programme 146 à hauteur
de 321 millions d'euros
la guerre en Ukraine impose une LPM de
renouveau notre modèle d'armée doit être
complété pour tenir compte de la
possibilité désormais avérée
d'une guerre de haute intensité en
Europe notre commission apportera sa
contribution à la réflexion grâce à une
mission d'information qui commence ses
travaux cette semaine mais alors que
nous attendons le projet de LPM nous
sommes d'ores et déjà inquiets
d'éventuels arbitrages défavorables sur
de grands programmes en cours au vu du
contexte international et des efforts
considérables effectués par un certain
nombre de nos alliés nous nous
attendions à une accélération de
l'effort or il semblerait que des
économies soient recherchées grâce à des
annulations ou des reports alors même
qu'il est d'ores et déjà acquis que
plusieurs capacités n'atteindront pas le
jalon 2025 fixé par la loi de
programmation militaire notamment le
format Rafale en raison de l'export
croate les frégates de défense et
l'intervention en raison de l'export
grec ou encore de l'eurodrome sur lequel
je ne me pesantirai pas mais qui a
bientôt presque 6 ans de retard
le système de drone tactique et les
véhicules blindés légers régénérés
monsieur le ministre la commission a
émis un avis favorable sur ce budget
afin de permettre à nos armées de
bénéficier de la remontée en puissance
en cours mais il est bien évident que la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
sur laquelle nous allons commencer à
travailler sera le moment de vérité je
vous remercie la collègue et le cycle
des rapporteurs se conclut avec madame
Hélène Conway mouray rapporteur pour
avis
et toujours pour 3 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
comme mon collègue Cédric Perrin est
entré dans le détail des questions
relatives au programme 146 je voudrais
vous interroger sur deux points d'ordre
plus général ce budget de la défense
suit l'augmentation budgétaire prévue en
2018 par la LPM mais la guerre en
Ukraine nous oblige à porter un regard
nouveau sur cette trajectoire dans un
contexte international profondément
transformé où la guerre conventionnelle
à haute intensité a fait son retour en
effet le 24 février 2022 constitue un
tournant historique et géostratégique
majeur pour l'Europe et le reste du
monde
cette guerre nous demande d'analyser nos
forces et nos faiblesses nous disposons
d'un taux indéniable à commencer par une
armée aguerri professionnelle
bénéficiant de technologies parmi les
plus avancées au monde qui reposent sur
une Des robustes et façonnée par la
commande de l'État les armes que nous
avons livrées à l'Ukraine à l'image du
canon César sont des armes qui font la
différence sur le champ de bataille mais
avec 18 exemplaires c'est presque un
quart de nos stocks que nous avons cédé
ce chiffre illustre nous faiblesse en
termes de volume sans compter la vétusté
de certains équipements comme le VAB qui
a plus de 40 ans mais demeures moins
services dans l'attente de son
remplacement par le griffon prévu pour
2030 mais nous lacunes sont encore plus
criante en matière de drone de défense
solaire ou de capacité de suppression
des défenses aériennes adverse nos
armées sont en effet formatées pour
mener des opérations sur des théâtres
extérieures la protection du territoire
agir en coalition et repose surtout sur
la maîtrise de notre espace aérien
monsieur le ministre une vision nouvelle
s'impose fondée sur un questionnement
prospectif qui semble jusqu'à leur faire
défaut
suis pas sûr que la nouvelle revue
stratégique est complètement pris la
mesure de ce défi où en est la réflexion
sur notre ambition des défenses
nationales voire européenne où est cette
vision globale et un cadrage plus précis
qui doivent être à la base de la
prochaine LPM mon deuxième point porte
sur la dissuasion qui est l'une des
pierres angulaires dans notre modèle
d'armée le chantage nucléaire de la
Russie et la possibilité d'une arme
nucléaire sur un champ de bataille en
Europe sont des données nouvelles
faut-il faire évoluer nos doctrines sur
le plan financier nous avions compris
lors de l'examen de la LPM en cours que
l'accélération de l'effort en fin de
période avec les marches à 3 milliards
d'euros devait notamment servir à
financer la montée en puissance du
renouvellement des différentes
composantes de la dissuasion or monsieur
le ministre l'un n'apparaît pas
clairement dans les différentes lignes
budgétaires une partie de l'effort
est-elle reportée je sais ces questions
sensibles mais un minimum de
transparence est nécessaire quand vous
nous demandez de vous suivre sur les
choix stratégiques et donc budgétaire
que vous faites
enfin si l'ensemble des ministères que
vous devez fédérer monsieur le ministre
pour sensibiliser les acteurs
économiques et la société civile aux
enjeux de souveraineté de défense le
ministère des armées devait être au
coeur de la réflexion devrait être au
cœur de la réflexion sur l'économie de
guerre et la solidarité
interministérielle être pleinement
activée est-ce que ce sera le cas pour
le financement de la contribution
française à la facilité européenne de
paix comme cela a été le cas pour les
surcous Ukraine avec la LFR de novembre
il faudrait enfin que l'accès ou
financement soit facilité et que les
métiers du secteur soient davantage
connus et valorisés dans l'attente de
vos réponses sur ces sujets de fonds qui
vont définir les budgets à venir et
notamment celui du programme 146 nous
voterons cette année les crédits pour
merci chers collègues donc nous passons
à l'expression des groupes et je
rappelle que le temps de parole attribue
à chaque groupe
on comprend l'intervention générale et
l'explication de vote et le gouvernement
dispose de 15 minutes ensuite pour
intervenir monsieur Lagourgue est le
premier intervenant pour le groupe les
indépendants et la parole
chez le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
le 24 février dernier les armées russes
ont envahies l'Ukraine cet agression sur
notre continent est une révolution
longtemps nous avons cru pouvoir nous
contenter de percevoir les dividendes de
la paix longtemps certains ont refusé de
croire à la brutalité des rapports de
force
dans cette période seuls quelques États
européens n'ont pas baissé la garde la
France en fait partie
et nous nous en réjouissons personne
aujourd'hui ne doute plus de
l'importance vitale d'entretenir une
force armée capable le budget de la
mission défense s'élève à 44 milliards
d'euros pour 2023 je veux rendre hommage
au gouvernement ce montant ce montant
correspond en effet exactement
la trajectoire prévue par la loi de
programmation militaire cette montée en
puissance permettra en premier lieu de
moderniser les équipements de nos armées
il s'agira notamment de maintenir en
condition notre capacité de dissuasion
nucléaire
depuis les menaces du pouvoir russe ce
sujet déjà essentiel est devenu encore
plus crucial nous sommes la seule
puissance dotée de l'Union européenne ce
qui nous place dans une position
singulière sur cette question
au-delà de la modernisation du matériel
il est également nécessaire de renforcer
les effectifs
1500 équivalentes en plein devrait en
août grossir les rangs de nos armées
depuis longtemps maintenant la guerre ne
se limite plus aux champs de bataille le
conflit ukrainien souligne avec force le
rôle de l'information et du cyberespace
nos armées doivent développer de plus en
plus de compétences pour protéger la
nation
cette diversification implique de
nouveaux recrutements tout comme la
perspective de retour de la haute
intensité
pour assumer notre mort notre part de la
confrontation avec la Russie notre pays
fournit des armes du matériel et
l'Ukraine
cette aide nous honore elle impacte
nécessairement le budget des armées le
contexte de géopolitique nous
contraindra à poursuivre notre effort de
défense plus largement la nouvelle
conjoncture internationale pose la
question du changement d'échelle de
notre industrie de défense la haute
intensité entraîne une attrition bien
supérieure à celle que ne force sont
connues lors des dernières années il
faut s'y préparer et nous devons donner
les moyens à notre industrie de se tenir
cet effort la nécessité remontée en
puissance de cette industrie prendra du
temps il nous faut pourtant aller vite
dans ces conditions la défense
européenne paraît plus que jamais
nécessaire c'est ensemble que nous
devons développer une base industrielle
et technologique de défense solide
nous ne pouvons que regretter les choix
fait par certains de nos partenaires
l'armement américain est certes
performant mais ce n'est pas celui qui
permettra à l'Europe de bâtir une
souveraineté stratégique en mettant en
commun le ressource et leurs talent les
pays de l'Union Européenne peuvent
parvenir à construire une force armée
solide la France plaide pour cela depuis
5 ans pour leur ni la présidente ni la
guerre en Ukraine ont achevé de
convaincre nos voisins le temps a certes
été ramené à la vie par l'invasion russe
mais le pilier européen reste la
condition de la dépendance de l'Union et
une fine et de sa sécurité
il était cet égard incompréhensible que
des projets comme le Scaff et le char de
futur connaissent tant de difficultés
nous avons besoin d'avancer rapidement
sur ces questions les examinerons
bientôt une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire elle doit nous
permettre de doter la France de moyenne
nécessaire à la protection de ses
intérêts nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à ce que les fonds alloués à
nos armées soient proportionnelles à la
difficulté des missions qui leur sont
confiées pour l'heure le groupe les
indépendants ne peut que voter en faveur
de l'adoption des critiques de la
mission défense je vous remercie si je
reconnais la parole est ensuite au
président Gontard pour le groupe
écologique solidarité territoire
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues dans le
contexte géopolitique instable de la
guerre en Ukraine nous examinons les
crédits de la mission défense dans ce
qui semble être le dernier exercice
budgétaire de la LPM 2019 puisque la
programmation suivante devrait être
anticipée d'une année pour adapter
l'effort aux troubles du monde et à
l'effort fourni par notre appareil
militaire en soutien en force
ukrainienne l'actuel LPM poursuit son
cours et tient ses engagements
financiers avec une augmentation de 3
milliards des crédits de paiement
portant le budget de la défense a été
rappelé à 44 milliards d'euros en 2023
pour éviter que cette augmentation de
crédit ne soit massivement absorbée par
l'inflation le gouvernement a fait le
choix d'un report de charge sur le
prochain exercice qui semble judicieux
en espérant que l'inflation soit jugulée
car ces reports représenteront 15% des
crédits de la mission hors dépenses de
personnel l'an prochain
notre soutien à la résistance
ukrainienne au nord la France il impacte
logiquement les crédits de la mission
qu'il s'agisse de la projection de nos
soldats sur le fond oriental de l'OTAN
ou de leur reconstitution de nos stocks
notamment de canon César les écologistes
appellent de leurs vœux à la poursuite
de ce soutien qu'il s'agisse de la
fourniture des systèmes anti-missiles
promis par le Président de la République
ou à l'instar de nos voisins allemands
de la fourniture de char d'assaut au
pays d'Europe de l'Est pour que ceux-ci
puisse céder leurs chars soviétique à
l'Ukraine ce soutien à la République
ukrainienne à son combat pour la
démocratie et la liberté justifie à lui
seul tous les forts financiers
considérables réalisés par la France
depuis près d'une décennie et deux lois
de programmation militaire cela étant
dit alors que le Président de la
République a présenté il y a quelques
semaines la revue nationale stratégique
je ne suis pas convaincu que la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
doivent se fixer comme objectif absolu
de relever le défi de la haute intensité
avec les coûts que cela implique
la guerre en Ukraine a illustré la force
de la solidarité européenne et
Atlantique et à moins d'envisager une
improbable guerre avec nos voisins
directs c'est dans ce cadre européen et
Atlantique que la France doit déterminer
son ambition militaire et envisager
l'effort financier afférent
les sujets ne manqueront pas au-delà de
l'effort d'équipement considérable
réalisé et à réaliser je pense à
l'attractivité de nos armées au statut
de nos militaires alors rémunération
alors conditions de vie au défi
important que représente la fidélisation
de nos soldats et nos soldats d'autant
que notre armée de plus en plus
sollicitée qu'il s'agisse du contexte
géopolitique incertain ou des tâches
plus domestiques pour épauler la
sécurité civile face à multiplication
des catastrophes naturelles sur notre
sol monsieur le ministre votre
prédécesseur évoquait sans totalement
convaincre des budgets à hauteur d'homme
forcée de constater que cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas ces cinq dernières
années je salue néanmoins le nouveau
plan ambition logement qui trouve une
concrétisation dans les crédits de ce
PLF qui représentent un saut qualitatif
important et qu'il faudra poursuivre la
qualité de vie nos soldats et soldats
doit impérativement profiter des efforts
financiers considérables auxquels la
nation constante pour nos armées gageons
que nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens
ne l'envisagent pas autrement
se confort passera notamment par la
rénovation énergétique des logements
militaires qui doit impérativement être
accéléré l'objectif d'éradication des
chaudières fioules en 2031 est trop
lointain et bien trop restrictif c'est
vers une rénovation globale des
bâtiments militaires que nous devons
aller c'est un enjeu écologique comme un
enjeu financier puisque la défense et le
premier poste énergétique de l'État en
puissance consommée comme en argent
public dépensé on ne va pas faire porter
l'effort sur nos soldats en OPEX en
revanche la sobriété du bâti comme de la
logistique en période de paix doit être
au cœur des axes de la prochaine loi de
programmation cela implique également de
concevoir des équipements notamment des
véhicules de combat plus économes en
énergie ce qui est le mérite de combiner
la sobriété avec une meilleure autonomie
en opération
enfin un mot pour conclure sur la
dissuasion nucléaire qui cette année
encore représente un investissement
lourd alors que la menace d'un conflit
nucléaire pèse sur le monde la France
doit s'interroger sur la nécessité
d'étoffer encore ses capacités propres
il nous semble au contraire qu'elle
issue du conflit ukrainien sévère la
réduction des arsenaux qu'il faudra
coller collectivement nous tourner à ce
titre nous reformulons notre demande
d'adhésion de la France en qualité de
membres observateurs au Traité
d'interdiction des armes nucléaires
voilà Monsieur le Ministre contrairement
au crédit de la diplomatie qui font pas
le figure à côté des vôtres et ce ne
sont pas et ne sont pas du tout pardon à
la hauteur des enjeux géostratégiques de
notre temps les écologistes voteront les
crédits du mystères de la défense en
attendant avec exigence le futur cadre
pluriel merci
merci cher président ensuite la parole
est à Madame Nicole Duranton pour le
groupe RDPI
et pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues cette année
2023 est une année charnière entre la
loi de programmation militaire pour la
période
2019-2025 et celle pour
2024-2030 dans ce contexte géopolitique
instable marqué par le recrudescence des
menaces et le retour de la guerre sur le
sol européen mais aussi la reprise de
l'inflation le budget de notre défense
pour 2023 est en hausse sur tous les
plans et suit la trajectoire de la LPM
2019-2025 mes collègues rapporteurs
l'ont détaillé précédemment programme
par programme c'est 62 milliards d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement 53
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
soit 8 milliards de plus en 2019 en
euros courant vont permettre d'aller
vers un modèle soutenable et ambitieux
pour que la France reste une grande
puissance militaire mondiale autonome ce
budget par rapport à la loi
[Musique]
il se traduira par la poursuite des
efforts en matière de construction
d'hébergement de crèches et de logement
en métropole comme en outre-mer
d'amélioration des conditions de vie en
garnison et d'accompagnement des
conjoints à l'emploi ou à la mobilité le
lien entre l'active et nos réserves va
être consolidée et ces dernières
revaloriser et c'est essentiel il s'agit
aussi de soutenir notre ingustrie et le
savoir-faire en matière d'armement et de
technologie militaires l'armée de terre
poursuit la modernisation de la Force
opérationnelle terrestre avec en
particulier des livraisons de véhicules
du programme scorpion ainsi que 18 chars
Leclerc rénovés la marine s'apprête à
recevoir la livraison de son deuxième
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque Barracuda
ainsi que des munitions d'importance
cruciales l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace recevra 13 rafales et 13
mirages de 1000 idées ainsi que des
missiles scalp 2 milliards vont
permettre de renforcer notre stock de
munitions avec notamment 200 missiles en
t-shirt sans missiles solaires sans
missiles RR 1,7 milliards seront dédiés
à l'acquisition des petits équipements à
hauteur d'hommes pour nos soldats les
investissements dans les domaines clés
pour le conflit de demain ne sont pas à
négliger le renseignement l'espace le
cyberespace et le numérique bénéficient
d'abondement conséquent les admissions
au service actif des frégates de défense
et d'intervention et des bâtiments
ravitailleurs de force ainsi que la mise
en place du progrès du programme pardon
système de lutte anti-mines futures
seront les éléments déterminants pour
l'amélioration de la capacité de la
Marine à assurer sa fonction on ne peut
pas faire l'analyse de cette mission
sans prendre en compte la guerre en
Ukraine les crédits que nous examinons
intègrent cette nouvelle donnée dans cet
environnement géopolitique profondément
modifiée sur le flanc Est de l'OTAN nous
armées doivent préparer à un
affrontement de haute intensité avec les
programmes 178 entretiens programmés et
146 recomplètement des canons César il
ne faut pas considérer ce budget comme
une fin en soi mais plutôt comme un
point de jonction cette année 2023 relie
deux LPM effet la liaison avec les
enjeux stratégiques de demain le
président de la République a annoncé le
13 juillet dernier lors de son discours
aux armées la revue nationale
stratégique pour préparer la nouvelle
LPM le 9 novembre il a dit lors de son
discours à Toulon lorsque la paix sera
revenue en Ukraine il nous faudra bâtir
véritablement une architecture de
sécurité nouvelle il faut anticiper une
révolution copernicienne du mode de
conception des conflits c'était
nécessité pour avoir en 2030 l'armée de
la décennie à suivre et non celle de la
décennie qui précède
cet LPM nouvelle vous souhaitez monsieur
le ministre la construire en
concertation avec les parlementaires et
c'est l'objet des différents groupes de
travail que vous nous avez proposé le
président l'a bien souligné la loi qui
sera présentée au Parlement vient devra
dépeindre une France unie forte autonome
dans ses appréciations et souveraine
dans ses décisions vous l'avez souligné
le 3 novembre en Roumanie monsieur
Munich ce qui se joue pour l'avenir
c'est notre capacité à tenir de manière
fiable notre engagement dans les années
qui viendront être bon partout et en
même temps pour toutes ces raisons bien
entendu le groupe RDPI est favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de la mission
défense je vous en remercie
merci chers collègues maintenant la
parole est à sur Rachid tu es mal pour
le groupe socialiste écologique et
républicain et pour
rien dire
monsieur le Président Monsieur Nice des
armées monsieur le Président de la
Commission mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
alors que nous apprêtons à discuter à
voter les crédits de la mission défense
je souhaite débuter mon propos en
saluant l'engagement et le prochain
service des femmes et des hommes qui
composent nos armées monsieur le
ministre votre budget
dans un contexte particulier au regard
de la situation internationale et
nationale au niveau international
d'abord le Do mythe de la fin de
l'histoire né de la chute du mur de
Berlin et cher à certains spécialistes
étant volé la guerre entre les États et
malheureusement de nouveau une option
réelle et sérieuse dans les relations
internationales la guerre menée par les
armées de Poutine leader d'une puissance
nucléaire contre l'Ukraine en est
l'illustration
la guerre avec son lot de mort de
destruction et de drames et de nouveaux
présentes sur le nouveau le Vieux
Continent pardon et aux portes l'Union
européenne les anciens empires contrarié
je pense notamment à la Russie à la
Chine ou à la Turquie veulent retrouver
leur puissance militaire passé et
diplomatique mais aussi souhaite imposer
dorénavant une nouvelle lecture du monde
et construire une alternative au pays
occidentaux les différents votes à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies a
commencé par ceux condamnant
l'aventurisme de Poutine le démontre
comment ne pas interpréter comment ne
pas entendre les propos du président
chinois quand lors du 20e congrès du
Parti communiste assume sa nouvelle
doctrine assumer la nouvelle puissance
chinoise avec au matérialisation
l'intégration de Taïwan dans le giron de
Pékin je pourrais également évoquer la
montée en puissance de la capacité
militaire chinoise tant sur les mers que
dans les airs
la volonté depuis son chinoises pèse
dans le concert des nations pèse dans la
construction de ce Nouvel Ordre Mondial
Alternatif et structure durablement
l'Indopacifique n'oublions pas que la
France est une puissance de
l'Indopacifique et donc première
impactée par la concurrence stratégique
entre la Chine et les États-Unis
la situation internationale c'est aussi
l'évolution notre évolution sur le
continent africain monsieur le ministre
votre projet de budget est le premier
poste départ du Mali et suite à
l'annonce du président de la République
de la fin de l'opération barkhane au
profit une nouvelle doctrine en termes
de présence sur le terrain il y a de
règles d'engagement de nos troupes
pour autant la présence accrue des
forces terroristes ainsi que la
plantation de nouvelles puissances je
pense notamment aux forces des troupes
Wagner de nous interroger sur
l'efficacité d'Ozo soit régie des 3D
développement diplomatie défense
enfin sur la situation internationale
comment ne pas dire un mot sur le temps
que le Président de la République
jugeait en mort cérébrale chacun jugera
ses propos chacun peut aussi constater
le relais essentiel de l'OTAN face à
l'agresseur russe
nous devons également intégrer une
nouvelle dimension de l'Alliance
atlantique après l'entrée soutenue par
notre assemblée de la Finlande et de la
Suède la Finlande fait que nous avons
dorénavant 1300 km supplémentaires de
frontières avec la Russie
votre projet de budget monsieur le
ministre s'inscrit également dans un
contexte national je pense là l'annonce
d'une nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire avant le parler de la
prochaine permettez-moi de dire quelques
mots sur l'actuel qui couvent la période
2019-2025 le groupe socialiste
écologister républicains regrette la
décision du gouvernement de ne pas avoir
activé la clause de revoyure
prévue par la LPM d'ailleurs et ce
profit d'un simple débat je crois que ce
n'était pas la hauteur de l'enjeu après
cet épisode
est plus encore après les propos du
prénom de la public et la Premier
ministre sur une nouvelle gouvernance
post-élection législatives et
présidentielle où nous attendions à une
autre démarche que celle que vous avez
engagée là encore que de déception pour
être plus précis je pourrais évoquer le
retour des anciennes méthodes en effet
c'est le gouvernement seul en chambre
qui a rédigé la revue nationale
stratégique vous avez fait le choix
d'écarter le Parlement vous avez fait le
choix de vous priver des compétences qui
réglent le Sénat et sans commission aux
Affaires étrangères défend ses forces
armées je le regrette
c'est pour cela que les membres de notre
commission ont décidé sous l'autorité du
président Cambon d'engager dès à présent
les travaux nécessaires à nouvel LPM
d'abord on lançant un travail sur un
retour d'expérience sur la guerre en
Ukraine le Sahel et la lutte contre le
terrorisme puis on engageant une
réflexion au travers des budgétaires
pour doter la France des armées du futur
monsieur le ministre le Séda sur un
nouvel foie au rendez-vous de la
construction de vallée LPM vous pourrez
compter sur notre sens de la
responsabilité et nos armées sont notre
soutien
le projet de budget 2023 s'inscrit
pleinement dans la trajectoire
budgétaire comme certains l'ont appelé
avant moi en apparence pourrais-je
ajouter car si on nous retrouvons bien
la fameuse bosse de 3 milliards d'euros
en 2023 et nous en félicitons il faut
avouer que le contexte économique avec
une inflation forte 7 % du 22 4% de 23
ainsi que le ranchissement des coûts des
fluides de l'énergie des matériaux
viendront grever cette hausse de 3
milliards d'euros d'ailleurs n'oublions
pas que lors du débat sur le PLF 2022
nous avons dû abonder Céline budgétaire
de plus nous allons nous avons
l'obligation de recomposer nos stocks
après la décision que nous soutenons de
transférer des armes comme le 18
annonces César à l'Ukraine
au regard la situation internationale
nationale économique nous devons
d'anticiper de passer dans un budget de
transition
c'est pourquoi nous devons examiner les
quatre programmes de la mission défense
à l'eau de différentes questions
quelles sont les nouvelles menaces et
quelle armée pour répondre
comment envisageons-nous de protéger
notre territoire ainsi que de renforcer
notre souveraineté en matière d'armement
et de défense quel rapport entre le
rapport entre la nation et ses armées
quel est notre rôle dans l'OTAN quel est
l'avenir de la défense européenne et
enfin quelle politique de ressources
humaines si des réponses se trouvent
dans ce projet de budget de 23
reconnaissons le nous devons encore
travailler afin que la prochaine ATM
soit à la fois un texte de
d'anticipation et un texte de
réalisation
permettez-moi d'ailleurs cet instant
d'avoir un mot sur l'actualité brûlante
je parle là de l'annonce d'un accord
entre Dassault son partenariat
concernant la réalisation du SCAF je
salue cet accord d'autant que le
contrôle attendu par la partie française
a été obtenue il faudra veiller à ce que
la capacité de vente demeure bien
industriel tricolore dans le
savoir-faire n'est plus à démontrer
si des succès existent la question des
coopérations l'équation des coopérations
industrielles nous avons encore ces
quelques sujets de préoccupation
d'autant que le brexit est passé par là
que l'état de la relation entre Paris et
Berlin inquiète et que le tropicis
allemand pour de l'équipement américain
demeure je pense notamment au char du
futur au boucle anti-missiles ou encore
au domaine spatial tout cela doit
renforcer notre volonté de soutien de
notre monde notre industrie de défense
aussi plutôt que parler d'économies de
guerre qui nous sommes un concept encore
à définir nous souhaitons plutôt
redéfinir une réelle stratégie et nous
en donner les moyens de la recherche
développement à la formation des
personnels des chantiers sont colossaux
alors monsieur le Premier monsieur le
ministre alors monsieur le ministre
c'est en responsabilité et en soutien à
nos armées que le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains votera ce
projet de budget du 23 c'est également
partenaire exigeant pour la France et il
réalise face au monde de demain que
notre groupe portera une vision
ambitieuse pour la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire je vous remercie
merci chers
monsieur ministre monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour discuter des crédits à
louer à la mission défense dans un
moment où le monde fait face au retour à
la guerre à la relance de la course aux
armements de tous les types d'armes et
dans tous les domaines terrestres aérien
spatial maritime cyber et dans le cadre
d'une réaffirmation de puissance de
l'OTAN non seulement euro-atlantique
mais désormais à vocation mondiale en
Ukraine nous sommes doublement engagés
par les livraisons d'armes prélevées sur
l'équipement de nos forces et par le
déploiement renforcé de nos forces sur
le flanc Est de l'OTAN au Sahel nous
dirons péniblement nos forces d'une
opération extérieure coûteuse et au
résultat politique catastrophique
l'addition totale est lourde pour nos
forces armées dans ce contexte
géopolitique inquiétant le budget 2023
confirme le respect de la trajectoire
budgétaire tracée par la loi de
programmation militaire en 2019
l'objectif alors affirmer était celui de
la remise à niveau capacitaire de nos
forces armées ce que nous se soutenions
toutefois nous alertions sur les
déséquilibres de la répartition des
crédits au profit d'une logique de
projection interventionnée les
évolutions en cours confirment nos
craintes et nous désapprouvons vivement
la préparation de la future loi de
programmation militaire préparez nos
armées à des conflits de haute intensité
est une chose et nous l'entendons dans
ce monde dangereux pour se défendre des
attaques possibles contre la nation son
territoire notre peuple ou les prévenir
mais nous préparer au nom de cette
logique à multiplier les champs
d'intervention extérieurs de nos armées
en est une autre le débat sur
l'augmentation des crédits doit être
liée à la nature des programmes mis en
oeuvre qui doivent réellement centrer
sur les objectifs de défense nationale
ou de programme européen dont nous
gardons l'usage souverain
le cas d'espèces du porte-avions
l'illustre bien bien que la France
dispose du second domaine maritime
mondial des ruptures capacitaires sont à
craindre notamment concernant ses
patrouilleurs de hotmer pourtant il est
préféré d'investir massivement dans le
projet du prochain porte-avion dans le
coup estimé à 5 milliards d'euros or
plusieurs études soulignent la grande
ville vulnérabilité de cette structure
en cas de conflit de haute intensité
notamment du fait de son indiscrétion et
de l'arrivée de multiples nouveaux
systèmes d'armes qui rendrait rapidement
obsolète et inopérant le futur bâtiment
plus généralement les états majeurs
préparent le terrain d'une seconde loi
de programmation militaire à 430
milliards d'euros pointe du doigt nous
lacune capacitaire si nous étions
confrontés à un conflit équivalent à
celui du haut Karaba ou encore à celui
en cours en Ukraine à cela s'ajoutent
les questionnements sur la capacité de
la France à tenir un front de 80 km ou
encore un conflit d'une durée de plus de
huit jours soit une mission monsieur le
ministre il faudrait faire des choix sur
notre format d'armée nous ne pouvons pas
raisonner en prenant comme référence des
pays agressés il y a deux ça seulement
quelques mois et qui ne dispose pas de
l'arme nucléaire la dissuasion nucléaire
est dimensionnée pour sanctuariser le
territoire national quel sens
accordons-nous à cette dissuasion si
nous redimensionnons tout pour nous
préparer sur notre sol à un conflit
interétatique dans la durée en vérité la
défense du territoire semble rester
seconde dans les concepts de haute
intensité l'économie de guerre telle
qu'ils sont avancées aujourd'hui il est
moins question de défendre l'intégrité
de la nation que de renforcer la
capacité de haute intensité de notre
doctrine interventionniste et des armées
censées la servir c'est pourtant ce qui
nous a conduit à des échecs marquants du
départ des troupes américaines et de
l'otanistan au repli de l'opération
barkhane et au fiasco de la Libye nous
continuons à persister dans une logique
produisent en cas ou déstabilisation
d'états violences persistance des
conflits et du terrorisme une logique
archaïque de projection dont nous
récoltons aujourd'hui les fruits amers
en Afrique aussi la récente revue
nationale stratégique ambitionne de
rehausser nos provisions en matière
d'opération extérieure de maintenir
notre capacité à entrer en premier dans
l'immense territoire du globe et des
océans pour quels objectifs au service
de quelle alliance de quel intérêt
monsieur le ministre nous parlons du
rôle de puissance d'équilibre quand a
joué la France sur la scène
internationale mais comment le jouer si
nous sommes plus indignés que jamais sur
les objectifs et les intérêts de l'OTAN
et des États-Unis au prétexte de
maintenir Laurent fantasmé de la France
dans le camp atlantiste aucune
initiative multilatérale de désarmement
formulé ni de construction d'une rente
coalition pour la paix envisagée et
pourtant le rayonnement de la France en
serait bien davantage éclatant
un format rehaussée de nos armées au
service de la sécurité nationale
appellerait bien d'autres questions en
matière de renouvellement capacitaire de
moyens de maintenance opérationnels des
effectifs et des armements de maîtrise
souveraines de nos industries
d'armements comment assurer cette
dernière quand la perspective d'une
autonomie industrielle de défense en
Europe vient de voler en éclat avec le
retour en force de l'autanisation
américaine de l'Europe comment
pouvez-vous garantir que les immenses
réduits dégagées dans ce budget dans
elle la LPM future consacre le
renforcement de nos capacités
souveraines de défense ainsi nous
regrettons une répartition des crédits
d'autant de temps de maintenir
consubstantielle de nos capacités de
projection au détriment de l'Afrique des
forces de nos territoires et alliés
proches et nous
et nous alertons sur la réflexion
stratégique qui anime ce budget celui-ci
ne permet pas à la France d'assumer son
rôle au service de la paix c'est
pourquoi nous voterons contre merci la
parole est ensuite à Monsieur Olivier
gigotti pour 8 minutes et pour le groupe
Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de
commission mes chers collègues le 24
février 2022 la Russie envahissait
l'Ukraine poursuivant son ambition de
puissance à travers une logique de
rapport de force dans le même temps la
République populaire de Chine poursuit
la modernisation de son appareil de son
appareil militaire afin de conforter une
stratégie sans cesse réaffirmée dans
l'Indo-Pacifique comme dans le reste du
monde la convergence stratégique de la
Chine et de la Russie ouvre la
perspective de contestation évidente
orientée contre les intérêts occidentaux
et c'est bien dans ce contexte que nous
examinons les crédits portant sur la
mission défense alors que la guerre est
aux portes de l'Europe
avec une hausse de 5% entre 2019 et 2023
les crédits de la mission défense en
respecter la trajectoire fixée par la
LPM pour venir s'établir désormais à 62
milliards en autorisation d'engagement
et 53 milliards en crédit de paiement à
périmètre courant la marge de 3
milliards en 2023 est respecté et ce
sont 8 milliards de plus qu'en 2019 qui
abandonneront le budget de la défense en
2023 on peut s'en féliciter et les
motifs de satisfaction existent et sont
nombreux les équipements arrivent dans
les armées à titre d'exemple pour
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace ce sont
très rafales trois avions ravitailleurs
multiro MRTT pour la Marine nationale un
bâtiment ravitailleur de force ainsi
qu'un second sous-marin nucléaire
d'attaque de classe Barracuda pour
l'armée de terre 123 griffons 119 Serval
22 Jaguar
les crédits dédiés à l'entretien
programmé du matériel atteignent le
niveau fixé par la LPM les diminutions
personnelles dans les services de
soutien ont enfin cessé ce sont
désormais 1500 postes qui seront créés
dans les armées en 2023 conformément à
la LPM
les secteurs prioritaires du
renseignement de la cyberdéfense et de
l'action dans l'espace numérique
continue de concentrer les créations
d'emplois à hauteur de 48% pour le
projet de budget 2023
la nouvelle politique de rémunération
des militaires en simplifiant la car la
part indemnitière de la solde renforce
la lisibilité de la rémunération ce qui
était très attendu enfin pour la
deuxième année consécutive l'enveloppe
consacrée aux études amont atteindra en
2023 le milliard d'euros ce qui était
indispensable pour financer les études
relatives au mgcs et oscaf à ce sujet
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez
peut-être nous faire part des avancées
les plus récentes si avancer il y a les
crédits nécessaires sont effectivement
prévus les autres thématiques de
l'innovation telles que la lutte
antidrone l'hyper vélocité le cantique
et l'énergie bénéficie également d'un
effort budgétaire pour autant le
satisfait site doit être nuancé car le
respect de la LPM est moins total qu'il
n'y paraît en effet l'inflation pèsera
hauteur d'un milliard sur la mission
défense 2023 soit un tiers de la fameuse
marche de 3 milliards
l'inflation a déjà pesé pour 200
millions d'euros en 2022 et séparant
retour des reports de charge que le
budget a été bouclé nous avons combattu
pendant des années cette gestion par
rapport de charges qui avait fini de
vous en souvenez mes chers collègues par
constituer une bosse de crédit d'une
année sur l'autre d'une ampleur telle
qu'elle limitait largement la capacité
de pilotage budgétaire nous devrons
veiller à l'avenir à une bonne
indexation sur l'inflation pour éviter
de connaître de nouveau une telle dérive
concernant la provision pour les Opex et
les opérations intérieures cette
dernière demeure insuffisante et la
solidarité gouvernementale n'est pas
mise en oeuvre cette provision sur Avène
chaque année insuffisante et ne permet
pas de prendre en compte le renforcement
du flanc oriental de l'OTAN elle doit
être réhaussée car c'est en gelant des
crédits puis en les réorientant en fin
d'année vers le financement des
opérations extérieures et dans une
moindre mesure des opérations
intérieures que s'exécute les budgets de
la défense depuis le début de cette LPM
cela finit par représenter là encore une
partie non négligeable de la marge de 3
milliards les nouvelles priorités
annoncées chaque année le renseignement
le cyber l'espace emporte notre adhésion
mais ces crédits sont alloués enveloppe
constante au détriment d'autres dépenses
initialement prévus dans le périmètre de
la LPM déjà taillée au plus juste
nous savons que les livraisons
d'équipements prennent un peu de retard
il en est de même de l'EPM la
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
des équipements la préparation
opérationnelle et la capacité des armées
à remplir leur contrat opérationnel en
dépend pourtant les améliorations dans
ce domaine ne sont pas au niveau espérés
niveau qui n'a pas été communiqué au
Parlement de façon lisible là encore
près d'un milliard c'est près d'un
milliard qui manque pour le PM depuis le
début de la période de programmation en
cours dans ce domaine la situation ne
s'améliorera pas avec la fin de barkhane
annonçait le 9 novembre il va maintenant
falloir restaurer le potentiel des
équipements sur place et les rapatriés
cette métropolisation des matériels
déployés coûtera pratiquement aussi cher
que la poursuite de l'OPEX en termes
d'entretien programmés du matériel si ce
n'est plus
nous approfondirons ces questions au
sein d'un rapport de notre commission
sur barkhane qui sera examinée avant la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
mais j'en reviens au PLF 2023 dans ce
contexte au vu de ses multiples nuances
que reste-t-il de la marge des 3
milliards nous sommes bien à la hauteur
des ambitions de la LPM qui était
sommes-nous bien pardon à la hauteur des
ambitions de la LPM qui était une LPM de
restauration nous le serions mieux si
son actualisation avait été un peu plus
législative la prochaine loi de
programmation et les budgets qui en
découleront année après année devront
permettre de faire face aux défis
actuels mais aussi de préparer les
confrontations de demain monsieur le
ministre nous vous donnons acte de ce
budget pour 2023 le dernier de la loi de
programmation militaire en cours mais
vous avez entendu nos réserve nous
inquiétudes et vous savez la tension que
nous portons à son exécution
le prochain budget sera le premier de la
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
il faudra qu'il apaise nos incertitudes
sur la capacité de nos armées à relever
le défi de la haute intensité et de
l'hypothèse d'engagement majeur à
l'avenir nous ne choisirons plus nos
champs de bataille il faudra que nous
soyons prêtes à tenir l'engagement là où
cela s'imposera nous avons parfois le
sentiment d'avoir perdu un an depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine une année
c'est pratiquement écoulée et les
commandes supplémentaires nécessaires ne
sont toujours pas passées
l'économie de guerre est un objectif
encore lointain nos alliés je pense
notamment aux États-Unis en ont une
vision bien moins théorique que nous
l'arsenal législatif adapté il existe
déjà nous avons fort à faire en la
matière mettons-nous au travail sur ces
questions sans tarder
donnons de la visibilité à nos
industriels afin qu'ils prennent leur
part dans l'effort à fournir donnons de
la lisibilité à nos militaires afin
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes avec eux
reconnaissants pour leur engagement et
déterminé à leur donner les moyens de
poursuivre pour la sécurité de notre
pays dans ce contexte le groupe
centriste appauvra les crédits de la
mission de défense pour 2023
maintenant la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Ravier au titre des sénateurs
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
appelés aujourd'hui à valider une hausse
apparemment inédite et des crédits en
faveur de notre défense nationale en
cela finalement rien d'extraordinaire
nous ne faisons que valider la
trajectoire prévue par la loi de
programmation militaire
2017-2023 et atténuer les effets de
l'inflation cependant cette
programmation a été prévue en tente de
paix et ces 3 milliards supplémentaires
paraissent bien peu par rapport à
l'augmentation de 100 milliards de
budgets de la défense allemande et de
150% de celui de la Russie cette année
je m'étonne que dans de telles
conditions alors que le Président de la
République nous demande d'intégrer une
économie de guerre depuis le printemps
et que l'utopie du couple
franco-allemand c'est officiellement
effondré nous n'ayons pas avancé
l'examen de la future loi de
programmation militaire d'un an
dans la revue nationale stratégique du
président de la République on entend
résonner l'objectif nébuleux de
résilience sans que soit posé le cadre
d'une véritable vision stratégique
politique et géopolitique de notre
nation pour faire simple quel est le
rôle de la France et de quel moyen se
donne-t-elle pour y parvenir de toute
évidence nous pouvons répondre que nous
ne sommes pas ici en présence du budget
militaire d'une nation majeure pendant
le covid nous avons été capables de
mettre sur la table des centaines de
milliards d'euros actuellement nous
avons engagé des dizaines de milliards
pour les boucliers carburants et
énergétiques en situation exceptionnelle
le budget de la défense devrait être
pardon lui aussi exceptionnel mais ici
face au retour de la guerre de haute
intensité en Europe sous ses formes
symétriques et asymétriques la montée en
agressivité des états puissances et la
reconstitution des empires hostiles nous
ne sommes pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu en
augmentant le budget de seulement 3
milliards d'euros
évidemment je voterai en faveur de
l'augmentation des crédits cyber de ceux
en faveur du renseignement des
financements pour les 7 nouveaux skdront
de gendarmerie mobiles et 200 nouvelles
brigades dans nos communes périurbaines
mais cela ne rattrapera pas la
suppression des vins de 20% des
effectifs militaires entre 2008 et 2015
qui a réduit nos forces à une armée
échantillonnaire en outre la récente des
fêtes commerciales de la France et de
naval group pour la vente de 5 vaisseaux
multimissions à l'Arabie Saoudite peut
nous inquiéter après l'annulation du
contrat de 56 milliards avec l'Australie
il y a alerte sur la compétitivité et la
crédibilité de notre industrie de
défense nous devrions nous inspirer du
parc baptisme de nos voisins européens
en matière de souveraineté industrielle
le projet européen d’avion du futur SCAF
qui se met très lentement en route est
un fiasco en cause l'Allemagne qui a
déjà jeté son dévolu sur le F35
américain économie de guerre est donc
incompatible avec les souveraineté
européenne tant vanter par objectif le
en même temps n'est pas compatible avec
la gravité des temps la mission défense
de retrouver sa place régalienne dans le
budget national il est inadmissible de
constater que nos soldats actuellement
déployés en Roumanie ont froid et fin et
vivent dans des conditions d'hygiène
déplorables alors qu'ils ne sont pas sur
une ligne de front il est temps que nous
accordions à la défense tous les moyens
de préparer la guerre si nous voulons
préserver la paix
merci cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur andriol pour le
groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la mission défense s'inscrit dans un
contexte géopolitique de plus en plus
lourd
nous assistons en effet à des
confrontations plus ou moins directes
entre puissance associé en provocation
et démonstration de force militaires à
l'instar de celle de la Corée du Nord
avec ses derniers essais de missiles
balistiques à la barbe du Japon tout
aussi grave nous voyons la contestation
par la Russie en Ukraine de Nord
internationale fondée sur des règles
dans la première fondamentale et le
respect de la souveraineté des
frontières dans le terrible conflit que
Vladimir Poutine a engagé en Ukraine
c'est aussi le droit international
humanitaire défini par des conventions
de Genève de 1949 et ses programmes
additionnels qui est piétiné par le
Kremlin
face à cela comme l'indique la revue
nationale stratégique présentée par le
chef de l'État le mois dernier dans mon
département à Toulon notre défense doit
s'adapter au risque de conflit doit
intensité en Europe et aux différentes
menaces hybrides
le budget qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui avec 3 milliards d'euros de
crédit de paiement supplémentaire
contient-il la promesse de notre
sécurité collective
il s'inscrit en tout cas dans la
trajectoire fixée par la loi de
programmation militaire qui peut voyager
au total 44 milliards d'euros en 2023
nous y sommes cependant cette évolution
sera sans doute à renégocier dans le
cadre de la prochaine loi de
programmation regarde du climat
bouillonnant que je viens d'évoquer le
RDS sera attentif à ce projet de loi
très attendu
pour le moment les nouveaux moyens de la
mission permettront cela a été rappelé
le déployer 1500 emplois supplémentaires
pour le renseignement et la sécurité
d'alimenter l'entretien des matériels
tout en poursuivant les grands
programmes
je pense notamment aux véhicules du
programme scorpion aux capacités de
communication satellitaire à travers
Syracuse aux avions gravitailleurs
multicolores ou encore aux hélicoptères
de nouvelles générations je n'oublie pas
la reconstitution des stocks de
munitions pour lesquels le Sénat s'était
fortement inquiété en début d'année
si rien ne doit être négligé je mettrai
la chance sur la vie à Sion de chasse
qui est cruciale dans le cadre de combat
de haute intensité à fort niveau
d'attrition le projet de loi de finance
prévoit pour le Rafale 6 milliards
d'euros d'autorisation d'engagement en
2023 sans épuiser tout le spectre
capacité je dirais quelques mots sur la
marine je m'inquiète du taux de
disponibilités techniques opérationnelle
des matériels de la Marine qui montre
des résultats légèrement de ça des
prévisions en revanche je me réjouis de
la mise en service du second sous-marin
nucléaire d'attaque de type Barracuda
Dugué de Trouin celle du premier
bâtiment ravitailleur de force et du
premier patrouilleur d'outre-mer ainsi
que le premier module contre mine
constitué de drone le fameux slam
pour autant toutes ces avancées
concrètes ne me rendent pas sourds aux
observations pertinentes exprimées par
mes collègues rapporteurs il y ait bien
entendu la question de l'inflation qui
relativise en effet une partie de
l'effort budgétaire le report des
charges comme solution c'est reculer
pour mieux sauter une nouvelle fois la
provision OPEX et mission intérieures et
sous dimensionnée tout d'abord si le
conflit ukrainien a tendance à
l'occulter nous n'avons pas fini avec la
lutte contre le djihadisme dans la bande
saelo saharienne sur le fond de l'Europe
sur le front de l'Europe c'est
l'engagement de l'armée de terre
française avec la réassurance sur le
flanc réseau l'OTAN en Roumanie qui va
peser cette fois
sans me connaître le contexte économique
est difficile il sera pas conséquent
nécessaire d'amplifier les efforts
budgétaires d'autant que notre soutien à
l'Ukraine nous conduira probablement à
poursuivre la session de matériel
la crédibilité de notre armée c'est
aussi l'assurance d'apparaître comme un
allié exemplaire au sein de l'espace
atlantique et en même temps le moteur de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne
sur ce dernier point j'ai une inquiétude
quand on va lancer par une satisfaction
le Scaff semble relancer selon la vie
d'honneur français d'assaut j'espère que
cela illustre le retour de bonnes
relations entre Paris et Berlin mais il
faudra pour cela que l'Allemagne
privilégie la coopération industrielle
européenne je pense notamment au projet
lancé par Berlin le bouclier
anti-missile européen mon groupe partage
la position irritée de la France ce
bouclier fait intervenir outre le
système américain patriote le système
israélien le fameux Dôme de fer en
concurrence avec celui de la défense
aérienne solaire de moyen de portée
franco-italien dit Mamba
si cette situation est inconfortable
mais elle peut aussi nous inciter à
renforcer encore les moyens de notre
défense pourra montrer l'excellence à
nos partenaires gage de notre
crédibilité et avant tout de la sécurité
collective aussi le RDSE votera les
crédits de la mission
merci cher collègue
et la parole est au président Cambon
pour le groupe les républicains et pour
12 minutes
sur le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
finance monsieur rapporteur
depuis une vingtaine d'années les
nations européennes accrochées à la
chimère de la fin de l'histoire ont
cultivé un dangereux paradoxe
alors que le niveau de la menace
internationale ne faisait que croître
les moyens qu'elle consacré à leur force
armées n'ont eux cc de fonds
le 24 février s'est illusion celle de la
paix et de la sécurité malgré tout a
volé en éclat et les Européens ont été
brutalement ramenés à la réalité de leur
renoncement stratégique dans cette prise
de conscience collective la France est
il est vrai réveillé un peu plus tôt que
nombre de ses partenaires dans un effort
de réparation de ces armées nous avons
entrepris des 2019 de mettre fin à
l'hémorragie de son budget de notre
budget militaire en 2023 cet effort se
poursuivra à travers ce qu'il faut bien
appeler un budget de transition de
transition d'abord parce qu'il sera le
premier à porter une marche de 3
milliards d'euros sur une trajectoire
qui doit permettre d'atteindre
d'atteindre les 50 milliards en 2025 de
transition ensuite parce qu'il sera le
dernier de la LPM votée en 2018 et qu'il
sera donc un tremplin vers la prochaine
LPM
le regard que l'on peut porter sur ce
budget et donc double en nous tournant
vers ce qui a été accompli nous
reconnaissons que la remontée en
puissance est entamée nous le constatons
régulièrement du reste sur le terrain
lorsque nous allons au contact des
femmes et des hommes qui sont la
richesse première de nos armées en cet
instant vous me permettrez de rendre à
nouveau hommage à l'engagement et aux
professionnels de nos milliers de
soldats déployés sur le territoire
national et au-delà de nos frontières au
Sahel ou désormais en soutien de nos
alliés sur le flanc Est de l'OTAN mais
en nous tournant vers l'avenir nous
devons aussi nous demander si bien le
devoir du Parlement si les directions
prises sont les bonnes et si le rythme
de progression est suffisant
au rang des accomplissements soulignons
que malgré les craintes initiales la
hausse conséquente attendue pour 2023 et
bien inscrite à ce budget nous vous en
donnons acte monsieur le ministre
les livraisons et les commandes prévues
l'année prochaine prolonge les efforts
précédemment engagés livraison de 13
rafales commandes de 42 autres
livraisons d'un second sous-marin
nucléaire d'attaque de la classe Suffren
poursuite de la modernisation de l'armée
de terre à travers le programme scorpion
encore ne s'agit-il là que de quelques
exemples emblématiques c'est pourquoi
au-delà de certains questionnements la
commission des finances est celle des
Affaires étrangères et de la défense que
j'ai l'honneur de présider ont été mis
sur proposition de leur rapporteur un
avis favorable à l'adoption de ces
crédits le groupe les républicains
partagent leur analyse il reste
néanmoins des points de vigilance tout
d'abord nous ne sommes pas naïfs quant à
l'impact de l'inflation ça a été
souligné à plusieurs reprises ici ce
sont ainsi plus d'un milliard d'euros
soit un tiers de l'augmentation qui
seront d'ores et déjà effacés l'an
prochain certes le gouvernement propose
d'en neutraliser les effets en reportant
ses charges mais ce n'est que remettre à
demain la résolution d'un problème qui
se pose aujourd'hui et c'est aussi
prendre le risque de réenclencher
l'effet boule de neige qui avait pu être
contenu ces dernières années
enfin des précisions doivent être
apportées sur la répartition des crédits
supplémentaires entre les différentes
enveloppes et sur ce qui est consacré en
particulier au renouvellement de la
dissuasion
enfin un dialogue s'est engagé avec la
BITD pour accélérer les cycles de
production et permettre aux besoins des
livraisons anticipées des lettres
d'intention sont promises aux
industriels mais où sont les commandes
supplémentaires notamment en matière de
missiles complexe notre commission a eu
la confirmation il y a quelques jours
qu'aucune commande de ces missiles
complexes n'avait encore été finalisée
vous nous l'expliquerez et vous nous
expliquerez comment on peut contourner
cette difficulté
les crédits de la défense augmentent
c'est une réalité mais aussi
fondamentale qu'elle soit elle n'est pas
suffisante car les leçons du 24 février
sont encore attirés la guerre en Ukraine
constitue un tournant stratégique qui
coïncide en outre avec la fin de
l'opération barkhane
ces deux événements majeurs doivent nous
conduire à une réflexion d'ensemble que
la récente revue nationale stratégique
n'a fait qu'effleurer de notre point de
vue elle porte sur le modèle d'armée que
nous devons développer pour être en
mesure de relever le défi de la haute
intensité
face à cette hypothèse qui se réimpose à
nous certains ont avancé l'idée que nos
armées ne pourraient couvrir qu'un front
très réduit sur une distance à peu près
équivalente de celle existantes entre
l'île et Dunkerque bien évidemment il
s'agit que d'un élément statistique mais
cela nécessite de prendre conscience de
nos difficultés d'épaisseur de nos
armées ce qui est bien connu a été et a
été souligné par nombre de d'orateurs
précédents certes nos forces ont
vocation à être engagées en coalition
quant à nous intérêts vitaux ils sont
fondamentalement protégés par la
dissuasion mais nous commençons je pense
à mesurer tout juste l'ampleur de
l'effort qui est devant nous et cet
effort il devra être porté par la future
LPM
bien sûr des enseignements doivent être
tirés de la guerre en Ukraine ou de
l'opération barkhane mais gardons à
l'esprit qu'on ne peut préparer la
guerre de demain en répondant aux
problématiques d'aujourd'hui avoir une
guerre de retard c'est toujours le
danger ultime et le piège à éviter
absolument l'histoire est riche
malheureusement en enseignement à ce
sujet c'est pourquoi il est crucial de
bien en percevoir les leçons
géostratégiques autant sans doute que
les enseignements militaires il faut
donc être à l'affût des signaux faibles
est-ce que nous le sommes suffisamment
c'est tout l'objet du processus qui
devait démarrer avec la revue nationale
stratégique des risques et des menaces
identifiées découlent les besoins et ses
besoins déterminent les moyens à mettre
en oeuvre cet enchaînement logique doit
être le fondement de la prochaine LPM
pour l'aborder dans de bonnes conditions
nous souhaitons monsieur le ministre
être pleinement informé c'est
particulièrement vrai des décisions qui
seront prises sur un chaînon qui est à
ce stade manquant celui de la définition
des besoins qui formera le satur de la
future programmation
en effet ces capitales notre effort de
défense devrait être compris pour être
accepté il devra être poursuivi dans un
temps long et supposera de lourds
efforts budgétaires il doit donc être
expliqué aux Français et pour réfléchir
et pour réussir il devra reposer sur
l'implication de chacun car s'il n'y
avait qu'une seule chose à retenir de la
guerre Ukraine ce serait peut-être que
la force d'une nation tient d'abord à
son moral à l'engagement et à la
cohésion de sa population à ce titre les
annonces du président de la République
sur la réserve opérationnelle et sur
l'avenir du service national universel
doivent être un peu mieux détaillés au
parlementaire il serait en effet
paradoxal de prétendre engagé une
réflexion sur la résilience de notre
société et de nos concitoyens sans y
associer cela même qui en sont les
représentants
et si nous devons durcir nos forces
conventionnelles conventionnelles ne
négligeons pas non plus nos capacités de
guerre hybride l'influence comme le
cyber et l'espace sont les nouvelles
lignes de front qui menacent au
quotidien les Français au cœur de nos
territoires et au cœur de nos
entreprises là aussi comme dans la
bataille entre contre le covid les
sénateurs et à travers tous les élus
locaux auront un jour rôle à jouer que
le gouvernement ne saurait ignoré
ce budget 2023 est donc avant tout une
rampe de lancement vers l'avenir une
étape dans l'attente d'une nouvelle LPM
ambitieuse comme pour chaque texte de
loi le Sénat entend naturellement y
apporter sa contribution et ses
modifications et il devra pouvoir le
faire en toute connaissance de cause
nous ne voulons plus apprendre dans la
presse que telle ou tel programme serait
menacé nous comprenons tout à fait que
la programmation ne permettra pas de
financer une liste sans fin de projets
de priorité elle imposera nécessairement
de faire des choix mais leur pertinence
devra pouvoir être discutée de manière
franche et ouverte la LPM peut être un
succès si le gouvernement comprend et
respecte le travail du Sénat le
législateur n'est pas un acteur parmi
d'autres une partie prenante ou un lobby
à inclure dans une forme de concertation
c'est du reste pour cela que nous avons
refusé la méthode des groupes de travail
pluriels nous mettons en revanche en
place nos propres groupes de travail au
travers de missions d'information
certaines démarrons leurs travaux dès
cette semaine pour enrichir la réflexion
de notre assemblée et lui permettent de
verser au débat des propositions
pertinentes des propositions
constructives car le Sénat vous tend la
main monsieur le ministre comme il avait
tendu la main à votre prédécesseur il
n'a pas toujours pris au-delà de nos
appartenances politiques nous sommes
tous ici animés par la même volonté de
servir la France et donc de mettre notre
défense sur des rails qui lui permettent
d'avancer vite dans la bonne direction
au cœur de la prochaine décennie vous
l'avez compris monsieur le ministre le
Sénat attend beaucoup de la prochaine
LPM mais si les attentes sont si grandes
dans un contexte géostratégique chaque
jour plus préoccupant c'est qu'il s'agit
au fond de la sécurité des Français et
de l'avenir de la France comme puissance
européenne comme puissance d'influence
dans le monde je vous remercie
merci cher président
la part les maintenant à Monsieur
Sébastien legrenu le ministre des Armées
merci Monsieur le Ministre Président
messieurs les présidents de commission
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
pour l'ensemble des propos qui ont été
tenus ce matin sur ce crédit pour
l'année 2023 plutôt que de lire un
discours je me permettrai peut-être de
revenir sur un certain nombre de vos
interventions et de d'éclairer le cas
échéant la présentation nationale sur
les différentes pistes de réflexion
question aux commentaires qui ont été
formulées bon un
quel que soit nos opinions politiques il
faut le dire c'est une loi de
programmation militaire avec une
déclinaison en loi de finance qui est au
rendez-vous je vais pas revenir sur le
chiffre historique si on regarde non pas
en point de PIB mais on va leur absolue
c'est le budget pour 2023 qui est le
plus important pour nos armées depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est une
réalité il trouve des explications les
technologies les besoins de financement
en innovation je reviendrai dans un
instant évidemment dans le détail sur
ces aspects mais il est clair que
l'effort budgétaires il est là il est en
rupture avec le passé ça a été dit avec
un certain nombre de d'orateurs à
l'instant des diminutions qui parfois
étaient justifiées c'est des formats
d'armée ont évidemment bougé au fur et à
mesure du temps notamment parce qu'il
fallait tirer les conclusions du fait
que la France était une puissance dotée
dans les années 60 et 70 que les guerres
coloniales étaient derrière nous que
derrière il y a 20 ans de lutte contre
le terrorisme avec évidemment la
dissolution du Pacte de Varsovie qui
avait produit un recarrénage important
de des armées dans les années 90 le
ministre Alain Richard en sait quelque
chose et que depuis évidemment quelques
temps il fallait réarmer je le dis aussi
puisque certaines diminutions de crédit
dans les années 2000 malheureusement ont
été faites à l'aveugle la RGPP a laissé
des traces importantes au sein du
ministère des armées avec des réductions
parfois à l'aveugle des effectifs qui
malheureusement enfin sont en voie
d'être réparés avec notamment cette loi
de programmation militaire en tout cas
cette rupture avec le passé et la
bienvenue ça prend du temps un certain
temps d'entre vous vous êtes revenu sur
la disponibilité des matériels il est
clair que pour par exemple un bateau de
la marine nationale entre le moment où
vous décidez d'un programme naval et le
moment où vous l'avez en disponibilité à
la mer il se passe du temps et donc les
années 23 à 24 25 vont être précieuses
puisqu'elles seront le résultat
opérationnel des décisions que vous avez
votées en 17 18 et 19 c'est l'inertie du
temps je le rappelle la France n'a pas
eu la diffusion nucléaire du jour au
lendemain la pratique pendant 10 ans de
programmation pour arriver à avoir des
programmes aussi lourds mais là aussi on
pourra y revenir dans le cadre
évidemment de la proche là programmation
militaire j'en dirai un mot troisième
élément l'inflation ne doit pas faire
mentir l'effet recherché vous y êtes
revenu nous avons proposé une solution
en gestion avec effectivement les
reports de charge c'est une pratique
ancienne ne faisons pas mine de la
découvrir elle n'est pas un sincère dès
lors que nous l'avons documenté devant
le Parlement on le fait pas en cachette
pour mieux vous mettre devant le fait
accompli on l'a documenté préciser et on
le dit au Parlement au moment où on
ouvre les crédits en tout cas on vous
propose d'ouvrir ces crédits donc non
c'est un risque que nous prenons mais ce
n'est pas une insenséité budgétaire et
puis bien malin ce qui savent combien de
temps durera cette dynamique d'inflation
et donc là aussi c'est une discussion
que nous avons avec les différents
fournisseurs notamment les industriels
je précise qu'il n'y a pas d'agios en
tant que tel que parfois d'ailleurs ça
correspond à des retards que les
industriels peuvent avoir c'est pas
forcément une bonne raison enfin c'est
quand même une réalité et que donc tout
ça en tout cas c'est une proposition que
nous mettion sur la table et elle nous
permet d'avancer je précise que lorsque
les facteurs ou le coût des facteurs
étaient favorable aux armées personne ne
posait cette question et que
légitimement vous pourriez aussi dire
mais Monsieur le Ministre comment ça en
2017 2018-2019 alors que les coûts des
facteurs étaient particulièrement
favorables vous en avez acheté pour plus
que ce que vous en aviez parce que c'est
aussi une réalité donc c'est une forme
de jeu qu'il faut assumer
démocratiquement et en transparence avec
le contribuable et avec les
parlementaires c'est ce que nous avons
fait ce qui me surprend dans les
différentes prises de position ce matin
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs c'est
que vous avez enjambé l'ouverture
historique de crédit en loi de finance
rectificative et que la plupart de vos
interventions ce sont retrouvés au fond
satisfaite parce que vous avez vous-même
voté il y a maintenant quelques semaines
plus d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires pour le ministère des
armées en loi de finances rectificative
c'est à dire que en plus de la marche
qui était prévu pour 2022 que vous avez
voté il y a plus d'un milliard d'euros
qui ont été ouvert notamment pour faire
le réflexe Ukraine notamment pour la
mission évidemment aigle sur le réassort
du flan est de l'OTAN donc je le dis là
aussi c'est assez baroque que d'entendre
que certains crédits seraient pris sous
plafond de l'Albert alors que
précisément vous les avez ouvert en plus
ce qui veut dire que pour 2022 au fond
nous sommes déjà pas loin des 3
milliards d'euros de milliards 8 de
milliard 9 ouverts pour le ministère des
armées c'est factuellement juste et donc
évidemment je voulais revenir je
rappelle que avant 2021 il y avait
aucune ouverture le finance
rectificative que en 21 c'est 150
millions d'euros ouverts et que là on
parle d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires c'est une réalité
puisqu'il évidemment il fallait
satisfaire à l'aide à l'Ukraine et merci
pour un certain nombre de rateurs d'y
être revenu puisque évidemment c'est un
point aussi important de notre actualité
stratégique pareil je ne sais pas qui a
mal informé la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense sur le fait
qu'il n'y aurait eu aucune
commande de munitions ces derniers mois
donc il faudra
mais complexe alors on y va de 200000
missiles 200 missiles pardonnez-moi de
moyenne portée ont été commandés en
novembre 5000 au but 155 mm en août 2022
8000 charges modulaires cet été en 2022
35 millions de cartouches en 2022 quant
au 100 Mistral ils sont déjà commandés
en cours donc je ne sais pas d'où c'est
source je ne sais pas d'où ces sources
viennent mais une fois de plus je me
suis engagé devant vous et devant la
commission lors de l'examen de ces
crédits en vous disant que nous le
faisions et donc je vous confirme que
c'est fait il est vrai que certains
commandent prennent du temps puisque
parfois ce sont les industriels qui sont
minutieux dans la négociation des
contrats et que nous sommes vigilants à
l'argent du contribuable et que nous le
faisons je précise aussi pour informer
le Sénat que nous allons procéder à des
commandes de missiles Aster en lien avec
l'Italie donc cette demande est
satisfaite et le chef est un major des
armées comme moi-même nous sommes
engagés devant la représentation
nationale à l'Assemblée nationale et
Sénat à tirer les conclusions
de ce qui se passait en Ukraine sur le
terrain des munitions et c'est donc
chose faite mais je pourrais évidemment
y revenir deuxième élément de réflexion
c'est évidemment le fait qu'une loi de
programmation n'est pas une loi de
fixation des crédits et pourquoi sinon
nous serions pas ensemble ce matin ce
sont les lois de finances ce sont les
parlementaires en loi de finance chaque
année de manière annuelle qui ouvre
évidemment les autorisations
d'engagement les crédits de paiement je
dis parce que il faut pas que la LPM
soit source de rigidité stratégique
ça serait une erreur elle donne un cadre
une visibilité elle permet d'engager des
dépenses importantes sur plusieurs
années notamment pour les programmes
d'équipements c'est la dissuasion
nucléaire qui dans les années 60 génère
la construction de votre programmation
militaire il y en avait pas avant parce
qu'on a des équipements qui nécessitent
5 10 15 20 ans parfois d'inertie
budgétaire et donc évidemment pour des
raisons d'utilisation de l'argent du
contribat mais aussi de transparence
démocratique il fallait le faire il est
clair que cette année 2023 est déjà une
étuilage pour plein de raisons entre la
LPM en cours je le disais réparation et
la loi de programmation militaire
prochaine
qu'au fond je pourrais qualifier de
transformation des emmenés de nos armées
et d'adaptation je crois que c'est clé
je le dis souvent dis-moi tes dangers je
te dirais qu'elle doit être ton armée et
je pense que c'est un des points sur
lequel nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
revenus ce matin on a parlé d'engagement
majeur de conflits
tantôt dans les mêmes discours ou
déclarations on prenait acte que la
diffusion nucléaire permettait de
défendre nos intérêts vitaux et quelques
minutes après on entendait dire mais
notre armée de terre n'est pas capable
de tenir un front de plus de 80 km à la
frontière il y a quelque chose
d'incohérent général de Gaulle Pierre
Messmer Michel Debré Georges Pompidou on
tranchait déjà cette question sur nos
intérêts vitaux je n'y reviens pas donc
oui merci à la ministre que d'être
revenu sur la dissuasion elle participe
des efforts importants budgétaires pour
l'année prochaine c'est vrai des têtes
évidemment dans les budgets du CEA est
plus précisément la direction des
applications militaires du CEA c'est
vrai également des vecteurs un programme
évidemment participent aux forzaarines
stratégique et puis surtout vous avez
madame la ministre dans les crédits que
vous allez voter dans un instant pour
avoir entendu votre position de vote
vous avez la modernisation des essais
née le notamment du programme SM et le
3G je pourrais revenir si vous le
souhaitez dans un format président
Cambon adoc devant la commission sur la
dysfasion mais il est clair que c'est un
effort important pour la prochaine loi
de programmation militaire les menaces
s'accumulent c'est un certain mal est
revenu sur la dopaque un certain d'entre
vous être revenu évidemment sur les
différents enjeux de sécurité y compris
d'hybrides c'est-à-dire sous la voûte
nucléaire on le voit bien avec encore
une attaque cyber ce jour sur un hôpital
on le voit bien avec la dite
informationnelle au fond la vraie
réflexion elle est pas tellement dans un
modèle que un modèle conventionnel elle
est dès lors qu'on a la voûte nucléaire
quels sont les menaces qui peuvent
guetter un pays doté et on voit bien que
l'hybridité la difficulté d'attribuer un
certain nombre d'attaques une forme au
fond
terroriste qu'on aurait conventionnalisé
on le voit bien d'ailleurs avec ce que
fait la ministre par un militaire Wagner
sont des sujets qui doivent nous
préoccuper et qui guideront évidemment
beaucoup la réflexion à venir moi ce qui
me fera beaucoup c'est que nous n'avons
pas suffisamment débattu ce matin des
missions qu'est-ce qu'on attend de nos
armées et c'est en fonction de ce que
nous attendons de nos armées que nous
étions clairs sur ces moyens capacités
et aussi et merci à un certain nombre
d'entre vous d'avoir parlé de l'OTAN
c'est aussi en fonction de nos alliances
que cela carène notre capacité et parler
de nos alliances n’est pas renoncé à
notre autonomie stratégique et à notre
diplomatie autonome telle que nous la
souhaitons même si sur ces sujets
évidemment il y a des différences
politiques entre nous elle ne date pas
d'hier pour être honnête mais une fois
de plus on ne peut pas regarder
uniquement le pourcentage de
mobilisation de tel ou telle ligne
budgétaire il faut dézoomer il faut
regarder cela dans une forme de tout
complexe puisque évidemment c'est des
menaces qui donnent le carénage des
moyens que nous devons mettre mis en
place en tout cas on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir troisième série de réflexions et
j'en terminerai par là monsieur le
Président je pense que chaque
effectivement chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités dans ce moment
particulier j'entends les propos qui ont
été tenus sur les exports rafales les
exports de frégate
j'en prends acte je l'ai dit moi-même
devant la commission je ne souhaite plus
que les stocks des armées servent de
stock tampon bon pour autant les mêmes
qui condamnent parfois les choix que
nous avons fait sur les rafales ou les
frégates sont ceux qu'il y a cinq ou dix
ans pointé du doigt les échecs d'export
du Rafale les mêmes qui aujourd'hui
défendent d'assaut comme s'ils étaient
attaqués par l'Allemagne j'y reviendrai
dans un instant à l'occasion de la
discussion des amendements non je veux
dire nous n'avions pas d'autre choix que
pour être réactif sur ces prospects
exports que de le faire nous avons subi
le succès est-ce que ça a vocation à se
reproduire la réponse est non mais voilà
je le dis devant la représentation
nationale je pense que c'est important
de le de le redire pareil sur les César
ce ne sont pas 18 canons César qui
mettent en danger la nation française
les propos en cela de Madame Le Pen
étaient tout à fait stupéfiants dans
dans la presse ou alors c'est ni même
là déjà la qualité des armées par
ailleurs le reste de leurs équipements
et ça a été dit par quelques sénateurs
du rôle la diffusion nucléaire sur la
défense de nos intérêts vitaux donc
n'allons pas inquiéter les Français de
manière absurde par des raisonnements et
des argumentaires complètement
stupéfiants sur la réalité de notre
capacité à assumer à assurer la sécurité
de la nation française je pense
également que
je ne reviens pas sur les alliances mais
il faudra évidemment que chacun aussi
clarifie ses positions je rappelle que
notre appartenance à l'Alliance
atlantique à l'OTAN a quand même fait
l'objet de déclaration tout à fait
stupéfiante de candidat à l'élection
présidentielle cette année là il y a
seulement 6 ou 7 mois ou 9 mois pendant
l'élection présidentielle et qu'on le
voit bien qu'entre temps nous avons
élargi le périmètre de l'OTAN à deux
pays ça a été dit il y a quelques
instants et que là aussi c'est un des
éléments qui doivent guider aussi une
réflexion stratégique et je crois que
pour le coup la revue National
stratégique le fait pour les semaines
qui viendront je
un parlementaire est revenu sur notre
échec en Afrique je ne parlerai pas
d'échec ne forces armées n'ont pas
échoué en Afrique je le dis barkhane a
été un succès le terrorisme a été
combattu avec beaucoup de courage par
les forces armées françaises avec des
pertes avec des blessés et si l'État
malien si le gouvernement malien ne
prend pas ses responsabilités
aujourd'hui sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme en aucun cas cela ne doit
revenir sur les épaules de l'armée
française qui a fait un travail
absolument remarquable là aussi il
faudra que l'on parle
de la lutte contre le terrorisme puisque
l'Ukraine ne doit pas écraser l'enjeu
sécuritaire au Sahel et là aussi nous
aurons l'occasion je suis à votre
disposition pour revenir sur notre
posture peut-être militaire en Afrique
qui à l'aune de la guerre
informationnelle à l'eau aussi d'État
qui vont se prendre peut-être qui vont
prendre des priorités de manière plus
accentuées sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous serons évidemment amenés
à y revenir enfin monsieur le Président
Cambon vous avez raison de dire qu'il
faut emmener les Français c'est déjà
c'est beaucoup d'argent on finit par
manœuvrer les milliards en disant que ce
n'est pas suffisant mais d'autres
pourraient dire mais attention mais à
quoi ça va servir etc donc je pense que
effectivement on a ce devoir de soudure
entre Français de manière en tout cas
que la question militaire soit une
question qui soit non pas consensuelle
je rappelle que la première loi de
programmation militaire portée par
Pierre Messmer à l'Assemblée nationale a
fait l'objet de quatre notions de
censure qui ont donné lieu à 4,49.3
enfin 4 49 francs qui ont donné lieu à
quatre notions de censure qu'à l'époque
le Sénat avait d'ailleurs refusé de
discuter cette loi de programmation
militaire en opposition au gaullistes
donc tout ça évidemment de nous faire
réfléchir en tout cas moi je serai à la
disposition du Sénat pour créer les
voies de consensus je défends les
groupes de travail que nous avons mis en
place parce qu'il permet de faire monter
un certain nombre d'individus
d'associations il y a beaucoup de monde
sur le groupe de travail réserve parce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'associations de
réservistes dans notre pays faut-il
commencer à les trier à l'entrée du
groupe de travail je ne le crois pas en
tout cas je vous l'ai dit monsieur le
Président Cambon moi je suis à
disposition du Sénat sur les formes que
vous jugerez utiles peu importe les
moyens seul le résultat compte merci
beaucoup
merci Monsieur Miss nous allons
maintenant procéder l'examen des 9
amendements portant sur le crédit de la
mission défense et comme tous les
orateurs ont été très scrupules avec
leur temps de parole jusqu'à présent ce
serait optimal que nous soyons encore
assez concis parce que il y a énormément
de travail cet après-midi
j'appelle d'abord l'amendement numéro 2
1266 présenté par Madame Gréau mais le
président Laurent qui a la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre c'est un amendement d'appel
parce que comme vous l'a dit notre
collègue Michel gréaume nous sommes très
interrogatifs sur le programme du futur
porte-avions et sur sa compatibilité
avec ce que nous disons sur conflit
enfin les orientations qui sont
nouvellement donné sur les conflits de
haute intensité s'agit-il d'un élément
pour élever le niveau de haute intensité
de notre interventionnisme
s'agit-il d'autre chose nous nous
interrogeons sur la vulnérabilité de ce
système d'armes qui demande pour être
sécurisé à fortiori dans un conflit de
haute intensité des moyens
considérables donc les 5 milliards qui
sont inscrits là ne sont probablement
que les premiers sur un tel programme
enfin nous nous interrogeons sur les en
de souveraineté rappelons-nous par
exemple qu'en 2003 après notre refus de
participer à la guerre en Irak les
États-Unis il avait fallu attendre deux
ans pour lever la levée de l'embargo
américain sur des composants et pièces
détachées dont les catapules du Charles
de Gaulle donc pour toutes ces raisons
nous avons beaucoup d'interrogations sur
les 5 milliards qui sont consacrés à ce
programme dans le
dans la mission et je souhaitais vous
interroger à ce propos monsieur le
rapporteur la commission
merci monsieur le Président on l'a bien
compris il s'agit d'un amendement
d'appel la vie est simple et bien sûr
défavorable parce que ça voudrait dire
que toutes les interrogations que vous
avez ne pourraient pas trouver de
réponse puisque vous supprimez les
crédits qui permettent de faire les
études et ça voudrait dire par voie de
conséquence certainement un allongement
des délais et une remise en cause de ce
qui fait la déflorons d'armée française
l'aéronavale donc pour toutes ces
raisons c'est défavorable monsieur le
ministre
oui monsieur présent monsieur le
Président avis défavorable alors on a
besoin des études déjà parce que il y a
le porte-avion en tant que tel mais vous
avez aussi tout le volet des études qui
concernent la propulsion nucléaire or
ces études pour la propulsion nucléaire
pour le futur porte-avions nous servent
également sur la nouvelle génération des
scènes et le 3G ou d'ailleurs aussi
actuellement sur la classe de sous-marin
nucléaire d'attaque Barracuda donc dans
l'ensemble des études vous avez un volet
propulsion nucléaire sur lequel on doit
garder à savoir faire français une
autonomie française parce qu'elle est
liée à notre dissuasion deuxième des
choses il est trop tôt pour dire si oui
ou non on aurait besoin d'un nouveau
porte-avions on acte que oui c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des études moi je suis un
militant du fait de garder un groupe
aéronaval je pense que c'est très
compliqué de de parler d'indopacifique
je pense que c'est très compliqué
d'avoir des partenariats avec un certain
nombre de grandes marines notamment
l'Inde ou autre si on n'a pas un groupe
ironaval je pense aussi que demain
éventuellement malheureusement pour la
défense de nos territoires d'outre-mer
un groupe aéronaval peut avoir
évidemment beaucoup de sens donc j'en
suis militant néanmoins il faut pas
balayer d'un revers de main vos
arguments parce que la question de la
vulnérabilité sur un engagement majeur
est un argument qui revient souvent et
donc moi j'ai demandé à ce que
l'état-major de la marine soit la
disposition aussi des parlementaires
dans le cadre de la construction de la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
peut-être pour mieux réaffiner les
missions opérationnelles qu'est-ce qu'on
attend d'un porte-avion demain voilà
donc avis défavorable ou retrait mais je
comprends l'appel de réflexion sur ce
sujet
retirez merci sur le président ensuite
madame Gréau mais le président Laurent
sur 1263
oui merci monsieur le Président celui-là
n'est pas un amendement d'appels
l'amendement qui a déjà été porté par
les trois députés polynésiens de
Polynésie française qui comme vous le
savez siège au groupe GDR aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale la France dispose
du second territoire maritime au monde
et pourtant nous avons de nombreuses
lacunes capacités pour assurer notre
souveraineté sur la zone économique
exclusive polynésienne et
ça a notamment comme conséquence
l'intrus l'intrusion courante de toniers
étrangers dans cette zone économique ces
intrusions réduisent la quantité de
ressources halieutiques disponibles pour
le peuple polynésien et altere également
la biodiversité marine de son territoire
l'acquisition de deux patrouilleurs
outre-mer dont la mise en service est
prévue pour les années 2024 et 2025
permet une modernisation des moyens de
surveillance et de protection de la
Marine nationale toutefois le nombre
reste tout de même suffisant pour
couvrir une zone de surveillance dont la
superficie et de plus de 5 millions de
kilomètres carrés l'acquisition de deux
patrouilleurs outre-mer supplémentaires
qui est l'objet de cet amendement
permettrait de rendre véritablement
efficient notre capacité de surveillance
dans cette zone économique polynésienne
et c'est le sens de cette amendement
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
remercier le sénateur Laurent de
l'analyse qu'il fait de la situation
puisque dans un rapport que j'ai remis
récemment dans la commission des
finances j'arrivais au même conclusion
sur la situation pour autant j'arrive
pas à la même conclusion sur
l'amendement et je vous prie bien
vouloir m'en excuser tout simplement
parce que je pense que ce débat est
important et qui doit trouver sa place
dans la future loi de programmation
militaire sur l'ensemble du dispositif
de souveraineté nationale donc c'est une
demande de retrait le ministre
retrait ou défavorable mais pour des
raisons assez précises bon un déjà c'est
un sujet de prochaine loi de
programmation militaire c'est évident de
en partie satisfait puisque un nouveau
patrouilleur outre-mer arrive cette
année 3 oui vous avez raison il va
falloir durcir sur la protection des
Outre-mer moi je souhaite un titre
outremer dans notre programmation
militaire qui permet de fléchir les
choses est-ce que ça sera forcément la
réponse par un bateau j'en suis pas
complètement certain l'utilisation des
drones par exemple sur un territoire
comme la Polynésie qui est aussi grand
que l'Europe est posée la question de
patrouilleur maritime par le ciel aussi
est-ce que la réponse est forcément sur
des moyens mis à la mer j'en suis pas
forcément certain au moment où on se
parle ça fait partie du travail qu'on
est en train d'effectuer sur lequel on
pourra revenir évidemment dans le cadre
de la préparation de la reprogrammation
militaire donc avis défavorable et je me
permets juste un clin d'oeil de forme je
parle pas de peuple polynésien parce que
polynésiens font intégralement partie du
peuple mais je sais que vous l'avez fait
sans malice
c'est la Constitution en effet nous
entendu je mets on voit pas dans la
parole oui dans sur une explication de
l'autre parce que si nous partageons
effectivement ce que veut dire puis à
Laurent mais aussi le ministre par
rapport effectivement à l'indopathique
largement l'autre mère et qu'on a
vraiment effectivement cette cette
nécessité de renforcer notre présence au
contrôle par rapport aux questions
militaires mais également à des
questions de pêche et autres pour autant
de conscient que c'est effectivement un
sujet de paix de loi de programmation
militaire et pas à l'occasion d'un
moment donc nous abstiendrons sur cet
amendement
présenté par nos collègues le 1263 qui
est pour
l'abstention donc il n'est pas de côté
nous passons 1257 présenté par Monsieur
guerriot caparole Merci monsieur le
Président
l'armée nourrie quotidiennement des
convives au profit au profils variés
puisqu'il s'agit à la fois de civil et
de soldats l'armée dispose
d'infrastructures de cuisine centrale de
production de remorque équipée et depuis
de nombreuses années la situation est
tendue dans les restaurants des armées
aussi en 2019 madame la ministre Parly a
souligné le besoin d'investir
massivement dans des équipements et
infrastructures de manière progressive
entre 2020 et 2025 si une partie de
l'activité a été externalisée à
l'économat des armées pour autant 197
restaurants devaient être maintenu en
régie l'amendement que nous proposons
visa bondé les crédits du programme 212
soutient de la politique de défense et
178 préparations et emploi des forces
pour la réhabilitation des restaurants
de nos armées au cours de nos rencontres
terrain nous avons été alertés à
plusieurs reprises du besoin d'accélérer
les travaux de rénovation nous devons à
nos militaires une restauration de
qualité et de bonnes conditions
d'hygiène la crise du covid la démontrer
aussi le choix d'une politique de
recrutement à la hausse implique le
soutien logistique suive suite au
réformes conduites entre 2008 et 2015 le
service du commissariat des armées a
perdu pas moins de 30 % de ses effectifs
avec 9000 postes qui ont été supprimés
ces réformes ont également entraîné une
sous-capitalisation chronique dans les
infrastructures et les équipements de
nos armées nous savons mes chers
collègues l'importance de la qualité du
soutien pourtant trop souvent délaissé
au profit de l'opérationnel dans le
mesure où nous devons respecter
l'équilibre budgétaire il me semble que
nous pouvons trouver des marges de
manœuvre à partir du programme de 146
nous proposons une menoration
raisonnable en autorisation d'engagement
et en crédit de paiement lui égard à
l'importance du budget alloué au 46 au
146 ce programme pourra maintenir notre
ambition d'améliorer et de renouveler
l'ensemble de nos capacités je voudrais
rappeler que depuis 2017 les crédits du
programme 146 ont en 5 ans augmenté de
50% en passant de 10 à 15,4 milliards
d'euros au total ce programme représente
plus de 35% des crédits d'ensemble de la
mission de défense c'est pour la que
c'est la raison pour laquelle il m'a
semblé possible de faire ce
rééquilibrage il est très important de
mieux doter la fonction de restauration
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à voter
cette amendement
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement Joël guerrios soulève un
sujet sensible qui n'est pas nouveau je
serais tenté de faire deux observations
est-ce que nous sommes certains de
pouvoir dépenser la somme de 23 millions
qui est proposé puisque ça n'a pas été
prévu puis la deuxième raison c'est une
raison un peu de fond à savoir que nous
sommes un certain nombre dans
l'hémicycle régulièrement reproché au
gouvernement de pomper dans la ligne des
équipements pour financer du
fonctionnement ou des investissements de
moindre importance donc sur le fond moi
ça me pose un problème la vie de la
commission c'est sagesse avec la ville
gouvernement mais si le gouvernement
devait donner un avis favorable
peut-être faudrait-il revoir le montant
des crédits alloués je pense monsieur
guerriot qu'avec vos collègues
cosignataires vous souhaitez donner le
signal je partage l'idée qu'il faille
donner ce signal mais il me semble qu'il
aime notre signal mauvais et qu'il faut
éviter de donner c'est celui de faire de
la variable d'ajustement sur les crédits
qui a sur la pérennité de nos armées
merci monsieur le Président a raison de
vouloir se signal puisque
ne rien faire conduire à dire aux forces
aux armées que tout va bien au quotidien
dans les régiments les bases la réalité
c'est que la constitution des bases de
défense a été utile certains égards mais
a quand même abîmé certaines fonctions
de soutien qui ont parfois eu du mal à
développer et donner leurs effets c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire avec ce paradoxe
contrairement à ce que le sénateur
ravier je ne sais pas où il est il est
parti bon disait tout à l'heure en
relayant de fausses informations que
mediapart avait publié c'est que souvent
en OPEX
mais souvent en OPEX la nourriture est
de bonne qualité et ça fonctionne bien
parce qu'on revient à un modèle
d'organisation des forces avec le
commissariat et c'est quand on se
retrouve sur le territoire national en
garnison dans les bases aériennes dans
les bases navales ou dans les régiments
qu'il y a des difficultés donc aider le
score est une est une bonne chose donc
moi c'est un avis favorable sur cet
amendement c'est interdit déjà raison de
de peut-être poser la question parce que
c'est 23 millions après on peut
peut-être le corriger en gestion le cas
échéant dans un échange avec avec les
parlementaires sur la ligne pour les
capacités il y a un tout petit peu de
marge de manœuvre je pense aussi que
c'est pour cela que le sénateur a déposé
cet amendement et puis ça nous rappelle
aussi que le programmation militaire
sont une chose mais que évidemment ça
reste le Parlement qui est en loi de
finance chaque année peut quand même
évidemment ventiler les lignes de crédit
et c'est une bonne chose donc retrait de
la Commission et favorable du
Gouvernement donc présume
j'ai mal entendu
d'accord donc je me suis perdra ensuite
qu'il demande la parole et Madame
merci monsieur le Président moi je
rebondis sur ce qu'a dit le rapporteur
de neige je pense qu'on peut pas en
permanence vouloir ponctionner sur le
p146 parce que c'est ce qui se passe en
général quand on a besoin de rechercher
des crédits pour de fonctionnement et se
plaindre ensuite à la tribune que les
crédits d'équipement ne sont pas
suffisants et qu'on a encore cette année
321 millions d'euros qui ont été
ponctionnés sur le p146 donc j'ai tout à
fait conscience et je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord ici pour le dire
qu'il est nécessaire et urgent de
travailler sur la problématique de la
restauration dans les armées mais pas
une fois de plus en sacrifiant
l'équipement du combattant et je le dis
clairement on a beaucoup d'occasions
d'évoquer ces sujets là parce que plus
tard en tout cas quand le moment sera
venu de s'exprimer à nouveau à cette
tribune sur ces questions de la j'allais
dire de déroulement du p146 sur l'année
2023 on viendra à nouveau se plaindre
d'un certain nombre de baisse de crédit
donc oui moi je suis entièrement
favorable à ce que sur la restauration
en face des efforts considérables
nécessaire la LPM à hauteur d'homme
c'était aussi ça je pense qu'il y a des
infos à faire mais je pense qu'il ne
faut pas le faire au détriment du p146
il faut le faire d'une autre manière et
ça je laisse évidemment le soin au
gouvernement d'essayer de trouver les
moyens de restaurer notre restauration
mais pas au détriment du p146 s'il vous
plaît madame
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je reprends les arguments
finalement que je partage avec Cédric
Perrin c'est vrai que c'est un
amendement qui est parfaitement en phase
avec l'esprit de la LPM une loi de
programmation militaire à hauteur
d'homme et de femmes dans lequel bien
sûr la restauration
sous son rôle mais moi je voudrais quand
même questionner l'opportunité de gâcher
les crédits sur le programme 146
monsieur le ministre si vous êtes
favorable à cet amendement pourquoi
alors ne pas avoir alloué les crédits
nécessaires à la restauration si ça doit
être une priorité plutôt que finalement
de ponctionner un programme où
aujourd'hui la guerre Ukraine nous
montre que nous avons un manque de
matériel que nous avons un besoin criant
d'en obtenir de nouveau et donc pourquoi
affaiblir un budget qui devrait être
prioritaire et lemeurer même si par
ailleurs en effet il est important en
nombre de crédit et sincèrement je pense
que si on devait sonder les militaires
leur demander si la restauration ou leur
sécurité
est prioritaire lequel des deux il
choisirait je ne pense pas qu'il irait
sur la nourriture par rapport à leur
sécurité et à leur équipement et
Monsieur guerriot explique son vote oui
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
voudrais remercier mes collègues qui
tousse unanimant reconnaissent le besoin
de faire ses efforts et d'accélérer dans
le domaine de la mise aux normes et de
la normalisée et de la modernisation de
notre restauration au service de nos
militaires c'est un besoin urgence tu as
besoin qu'il faut pour véritablement
prendre en considération et ensuite et
bien évidemment nous sommes face à un
dilemme c'est comment le financer eu
égard à ce buzz dilemme moi il m'a
semblé que le 146 certes nous avons
beaucoup de demandes sur le 146 mais il
faut quand même notifier que c'est un
budget qui a particulièrement augmenté
puisque comme je rappelle tout à l'heure
il y a eu il y a eu il y a eu 50%
d'augmentation depuis 2017 c'était en
moins de 5 ans donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pris ce choix fait ce
choix en considérant que ça restait un
montant très faible eu égard à
15,4 milliards d'euros du 146 il m'a
semblé qu'on pouvait peut-être trouver
des marges sur ce sur ce 146 mais c'est
toujours un choix difficile à effectuer
pour ma part je reste sur cette position
et j'attends que effectivement une
contre-proposition et on verra si on
pouvait nous en sortir mais en tout cas
il faut répondre à ce besoin concernant
la restauration j'en suis persuadé j'ai
donc un avis de retrait nos satisfaits
de la Commission et un avis
et un avis favorable du Gouvernement
donc qui est pour l'amendement
contre
les repousser monsieur Delhaize
rapporteur pour la commission des
finances l'amendement numéro 10
merci monsieur le Président féministe
j'ai hésité à maintenir cet amendement
puisque je l'avais déposé avant que
l'accord intervienne entre les
industriels sur le Scaff mais peut-être
avant rappeler que l'accord intervenu ne
signifie pas que nous sommes au bout de
nos peines l'accord consiste simplement
à se mettre d'accord sur le fait qu'on
va avoir un cahier des charges à
déterminer pour construire un
démonstrateur qui dans le meilleur des
cas voleront 2029 ce qui veut dire que
l'avion du futur ne volera qu'en 2040 ça
fait quand même beaucoup de temps et
d'ici là il peut y avoir un certain
nombre de mauvaises surprises et d'aller
à et surtout
souhaiter rappeler que l'accord entre
les industriels ça reste un accord entre
les industriels et que ce qui est
important c'est l'accord politique
monsieur le minis c'est vous le savez
bien et dans le contexte actuel de nos
relations avec l'Allemagne il nous est
important de vous entendre
sur le point de savoir où vous en êtes
dans cette relation
rappelez que les intérêts des Allemands
et les intérêts des Français sont partis
liés mais pas totalement puisque pour
l'arme nucléaire les Allemands font
appel aux avions américains et qui n'ont
pas la même problématique que nous par
rapport à la pontage sur le successeur
du Charles de Gaulle donc très
clairement avec cette appel avec cet
amendement pardon monsieur le ministre
souhaitez-vous entendre sur deux points
très précis premièrement quel est le
calendrier
et si ce calendrier n'est pas respecté
qu'elles en sauraient les conséquences
et puis d'une façon plus générale
vous entendent sur la question de la
relation franco-allemande mais aussi
plus largement sur la relation avec
l'OTAN dont le président de la
République nous avait dit il y a deux
ans qu'elle était en état de mort
cérébrale mais j'ai l'impression que le
mort est en train de ressusciter merci
et quelques sujet à traiter dans une
réponse à un amendement monsieur le
ministre
ce sont des sujets de thèse pratiquement
bon il est clair que c'est la Russie qui
a présidé la résurrection de l'Alliance
atlantique puisque de fait au moment où
le président de la République a tenu ses
propos l'Alliance atlantique était
devenue une alliance diplomatique plus
qu'une alliance militaire il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont et que
les planifications militaires ont repris
de plus belle mais on aura l'occasion de
revenir évidemment sur la relation de la
France à l'OTAN que la France a quand
même fondé je le rappelle et que le
général de Gaulle a souhaité que nous
ayons
alliés mes non alignés pour reprendre la
très jolie formule une très grande
autonomie stratégique au sein de
celle-ci qui d'ailleurs s'exprime par le
fait que nous ne sommes pas dans la
communauté des plans nucléaires mais
pour autant nous sommes évidemment un
des pays les plus importants atlantiques
y compris dans les différentes fonctions
que les militaires peuvent occuper sur
le Scave de manière globale bon un
accord est intervenu la semaine dernière
avec effectivement les différentes
parties industrielles si je peux me
permettre une remarque monsieur le
sénateur n'oubliez pas nos amis qui
souffrent beaucoup qu'on ne nécessite
jamais et ils ont bien raison c'est donc
comment dire un programme entre trois
nations européennes qu'elle repose sur
des diagnostics anciens on parlait du
général Lego tout à l'heure c'est de
dire si on ne veut pas acheter ces
avions à Washington ou à Pékin ou à
Moscou il faut que l'Europe soit capable
de définir une autonomie stratégie en
matière industrielle ça ne date pas
d'hier avec des hauts et des bas en
fonction des programmes et en fonction
des circonstances donc sur la question
du franco-allemand nous avons désormais
plus de 40 années de partenariats avec
des hauts et des bas sur le terrain
industriel je ne sais pas de quoi sera
fait les 30 ans qui viennent ce que je
sais c'est que nous avons raison de
définir cette phase 1 B tel qu'elle est
prévue parce que nous avons besoin de
réfléchir à l'air post-raphaal et donc
les dates que vous avez évoquées sont
les bonnes on parle bien des horizons à
2040 en fait il s'agit pour nous la
génération de décideurs politiques de
définir le cadre capacitaire pour
l'armée de l'air pour nos successeurs
bon donc c'est évidemment une question
qui nous oblige que cette phase 1 B quoi
qu'il arrive elle nous est utile j'ai
bien quoi qu'il arrive elle nous est
utile puisqu'on a besoin de définir ce
démonstrateur l'autre point important le
Scaff ce n'est pas qu'un avion et
souvent les piliers ont été mélangés sur
le terrain un peu médiatique c'est à la
fois certes le programme de l'avion sur
lequel il y a eu beaucoup de discussions
c'est aussi évidemment un club de combat
qui est véritablement le point sur
lequel on doit faire un saut en termes
d'innovation très importante c'est aussi
un environnement collaboratif autour de
l'avion en matière de drone avec aussi
un certain nombre d'applications divers
et variées donc on a besoin de ce
programme
cette phase 1 B est une phase
utile je le disais désormais nous avons
une revoyure dans 2 à 3 ans globalement
dans lequel on verra où on sera le
projet de démonstrateur et là
effectivement il y aura une discussion à
la fois industrielle mais aussi
politique entre état sur la mise en
production de ce de ce programme donc la
vraie revoyure si j'ose dire désormais
elle est dans deux ans je crois que le
ça redit au présent de la République il
était attaché à ce à ce projet et nous
nous sommes attachés à celui-ci sans
trahir sans compromettre nos intérêts
stratégiques vous en avez cité un c'est
évidemment le rôle de cet avion dans
notre dissuasion nucléaire vous avez
cité la famille mais je peux me
permettre aussi de citer tout simplement
les forces stratégiques cet avion doit
emmener la bombe française c'est un des
paramètres qui n'est évidemment pas
négociables et peut-être un deuxième
élément de nos intérêts de notre
identité monsieur le sénateur dans ce
projet c'est aussi notre capacité à
l'exportation où nous souhaitons rester
maître de cette exportation comme nous
le faisons aujourd'hui avec le Rafale en
Inde aux Émirats arabes unis ailleurs et
ça évidemment c'est un des points qui
compte aussi beaucoup nous souhaitons
pas sceller notre doctrine d'exportation
à des intérêts stratégiques qui seraient
trop partagées en tout cas nous ne
voulons pas mettre en danger notre
souveraineté on va aller en quelques
mots ce que je pouvais dire c'est très
compliqué de le faire de manière concise
en tout cas le programme avance il faut
le désormais le regarder de manière très
dépassionnée de manière très technique
en défendant nos intérêts stratégiques
je vais mettre quoi cet amendement de la
commission sauf si le rapporteur à un
nouveau propos il est retiré monsieur le
Président nous passons 1264 de madame
gréaume qui a la parole
excusez-moi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le 4 mai dernier le Canard Enchaîné
avait relevé révélé que le ministère des
armées aurait lancé un appel d'offres
d'un montant de 50 millions d'euros pour
des prestations de cabinets conseils ces
prestations concernées un loup pour 13
millions 5 13 5 euros concernant le
conseil en matière de frais de
déplacement et de politique de voyage ou
encore 8 millions 3 pour la définition
de la stratégie et du cadrage de projet
dans le cadre de la transformation du
ministère des armées un seul a été
attribué pour un montant proche de trois
millions quatre d'euros cette pratique
est contestable
dans un ministère régalien comme celui
des armées ou de nombreux éléments sont
classifiés ainsi nous proposons
d'aborder l'action de pilotage de 5
millions d'euros afin de permettre au
secrétariat général des armées de
recruter des personnels pour qu'ils
effectuent en interne ses missions de
conseils merci
la vie de la commission chers collègues
votre amendement fait suite à un rapport
qu'a rendu récemment le Sénat qui a fait
par lui
ce rapport était animé par Madame
assassin et notre collègue Bazin il dit
des choses très intéressantes mais
notamment il souligne les pratiques
vertueuses du ministère de la Défense
c'est-à-dire que ce rapport que vous
citez cet état d'un comportement sur ces
questions là du ministère de la Défense
qui est tout à fait remarquable avec des
procédures adaptées et donc pour ne pas
mettre la présidente assassie en
difficulté avec cet amendement je
propose le retrait
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président même même position retrait ou
défavorable peut-être ajouter un chiffre
puisqu'en 2022 en gestion
l'enveloppe dédiée à ces cabinets a
encore diminué de 40 % par rapport à
l'année 2021 tout simplement parce que
nous arrivons à réinternaliser
énormément de procédures et je vous
rassure même la signatrice quand il y a
externalisation c'est véritablement un
qui a pas le choix et de surtout les
habilitations liées au secret défense ou
en tout cas à la protection de nos
intérêts sont assurés assumer soit par
la DGA soit par la drsd en tout cas on
ne négocie pas avec cette affaire et
pour 2023 nous allons continuer de
diminuer le recours à ces cabinets
notamment parce que j'ai aussi de bons
espoirs sur les réserve et en
développant aussi une réserviste
d'experts on en reparlera de
programmation militaire on pourra aussi
documenter autrement certaines
prestation extérieure en passant par des
réservistes c'est une des pistes en tout
cas je mets sur la table
alors madame monsieur président
Laurent
oui évidemment c'est amendement n'est
pas en contradiction avec la démarche
de nos collègues Eliana Sassy Arnaud
basin que nous appuyons totalement
et à ce propos je veux dire que la balle
est aujourd'hui dans le camp du
gouvernement parce que les
recommandations et la proposition de loi
auquel a donné lieu ce rapport ayant été
adoptés par le Sénat il serait de bonne
aloi si nous voulons aller dans le sens
de ce qu'a dit notre rapporteur que le
gouvernement inscrivent à l'ordre du
jour l'Assemblée nationale cette
proposition de loi pour qu'elle aille à
son terme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on est fait les peut-être pas
indispensable de voter 7 amendement la
particulièrement mais en attendant
vous l'avez souligné monsieur président
Laurent avec grande impatience
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale de la proposition
de loi sur le cabinets de conseils qui a
été voté à l'unanimité
du Sénat il serait très utile de voter
au moment de l'examen des articles non
rattachés la proposition de jaune
budgétaire que nous faisons car celui
d'ailleurs un avis favorable de la
commission ce matin qui nous permettrait
au moins de faire le jour la clarté sur
l'ensemble des commandes en quoi elle
consiste combien elle coûte comment
elles sont évaluées et ça nous avons la
possibilité de le faire plus tard dans
l'examen de cette deuxième partie au
moment de des articles non rattachés je
vous invite à voter cet amendement mes
chers collègues face à celui qui va
venir donc sur le 1264 avec avis de
retrait de la Commission et défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
je vais retirer cet amendement mais je
voulais quand même dire à mon collègue
que je ne souhaitais pas mettre en
difficulté la présidente de mon groupe
et je rappelle quand même que le cette
mission sur les cabinets conseils a bien
été demandé par le groupe CRCE
donc sur le 1220 maintenant je suis la
demande de parole de Madame Conway
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est
amendement propose la création d'un
programme budgétaire dédié à la
transition énergétique au sein de la
mission défense il permettra la mise en
oeuvre de la stratégie énergétique de
défense structurée autour du tripty
consommez moins consommer sur consommer
mieux présenté en 2020 qui a débouché
dans un premier temps sur le service des
essences des armées qui est devenue le
service de l'énergie opérationnelle
c'est pas simplement un changement de
nom je crois mais la volonté affichée du
ministère d'aller vers une
diversification des énergies alors
pourquoi ne pas suivre l'exemple de la
Royal Air Force qui a annoncé l'année
dernière sur l'intention d'être à 0
carbone en 2040 et a fait voler avec
succès il y a deux semaines on a 330
avec un carburant alternatif il est
possible d'accélérer c'est un moment
propose de rassembler les actions
disparates les tendons vers le même
objectif et leur donner ainsi une
visibilité qui manque aujourd'hui et
puis notre recherche est développement
pour étirer parti des travaux engagés et
répondre aux appels à projets liés à la
transition énergétique et bénéficier de
quelques dizaines de millions d'euros du
Fonds européen de défense au vu du
contexte international et notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et aux
pays qui les produisent il est urgent de
nous engager résolument vers la
transition énergétique dès ce projet de
loi de finances le ministère des armées
doit y prendre toute sa part compte tenu
de sa forte consommation énergétique et
de l'impact environnemental de ces
actions en 2020 la consommation de
carburant représentait trois quarts de
sa facture énergétique le fait que le
terme énergie n'apparaisse qu'une seule
fois dans la rue stratégique pour
appeler que c'est un enjeu essentiel
doit nous inciter à bâtir à bâtir tout
un programme et c'est ce que nous
proposons en le dotant d'un virgule 3
millions d'euros qui permettrait la
réalisation d'une étude sur l'empreinte
carbone dans le pic l'optique de suivre
l'exemple de nos partenaires pour aller
vers le 0 carbone le suivi de
l'application de la stratégie
énergétique de défense proposée par
votre prédécesseuse afin d'illustrer les
résultats obtenus la réalisation d'une
étude sur l'empreinte carbone et les
résultats de la politique énergétique et
environnementale menée par votre
ministère enfin la rénovation thermique
du parc immobilier où vivent et travail
des personnels mais aussi ça serait le
lancement d'une véritable transition
énergétique pour nos infrastructures
merci monsieur le Président de la
Commission s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues je ne suis pas certain qu'il
soit nécessaire de modifier la maquette
budgétaire d'un budget de 60 milliards
pour intégrer un million 3 ça c'est pour
la forme sur le fond
sur le fond cette transition énergétique
est déjà engagée d'après les
informations dont je dispose et qui
m'ont été donnés
aujourd'hui on peut à peu près valoriser
ces crédits à 126 millions déjà bien
au-delà de ce que vous proposez et ça
touche notamment les infrastructures la
gestion de l'eau la rénovation des
chaufferies et à fond de protection de
la biodiversité donc pour toutes ces
raisons je pense que c'était important
de cocher la case écologique mais au
ministère de la Défense on est déjà en
avance et puis de grâce ne changeons pas
cette maquette budgétaire je pense que
vous pourrez reposer le sujet lors de la
LPM merci
la ville du gouvernement s'il vous plaît
le chimiste oui merci monsieur le
Président je pense que c'est un moment
d'appel donc retrait
un chiffre de 2 milliards d'euros est
affecté sur les bâtiments pour l'année
prochaine évidemment c'est pas une étude
qui permet de le faire c'est surtout les
cahiers des charges en maîtrise
d'ouvrage comme pour nos collectivités
locales au fond c'est dans la manière
d'agir dans la commande publique la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments la
rénovation des réseaux fuite d'eau sur
les bases aériennes régiment etc que
nous avons notre axe d'effort en
revanche madame la ministre deuxième
élément plus nouveau
l'armée est un grand propriétaire de
fonciers y compris de fonciers en zone
Natura 2000 et donc moi j'ai passé des
instructions pour que nous soyons un
propriétaire de zone Natura 2000
irréprochable sur l'entretien de ces
zones c'est là-dessus qu'on va mettre un
certain nombre d'efforts pour l'année
prochaine rénovation thermique des
bâtiments c'est la grande priorité parce
qu'on est propriétaire propriétaire de
fonciers en zone Natura 2000 en tout cas
on va avancer sur ce sujet mais j'aurais
l'occasion de vous rendre compte demande
de retrait
monsieur le Président Gontard
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président dont je voulais aller dans le
sens évidemment de cette de cette
amendement puisque j'en ai aussi parlé
dans mon intervention mon intervention
tout à l'heure je pense qu'effectivement
on l'a dit on l'a souligné des efforts
étaient faits mais on voit que ces
efforts peuvent aller encore beaucoup
plus loin je parlais de la du changement
ou de la rénovation enfin plutôt le
changement des des chaudières qui est
avec un objectif de 2031 je crois qui
qui pourrait être fait beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus rapidement donc je pense
que c'est vrai qu'il y a avancé sur la
question du matériel sur la question de
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
évidemment sur lequel il faut vraiment
qu'on aille beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vite donc je trouve que cet amendement
du coup le fait de créer un programme
dédié me semble plutôt intéressant et
puis j'avais une question puisque
justement le ministre a est intervenu
sur la question du foncier c'est vrai
que l'armée a beaucoup de fonciers
c'était moi j'ai une question sur
l'installation des éoliennes dans les
emprises militaires puisque c'est un
sujet qui avait été évoqué notamment
dans le dans la loi ENR puis qui a
disparu et donc je voulais savoir quel
était la position aussi du ministre sur
cette question là merci donc j'ai
madame condom
c'est vrai que en fait ce qui était
proposé nous sommes parfaitement au
courant de des efforts colossaux qui
sont qui sont engagés et de tout ce qui
se passe c'était simplement que nous
avons beaucoup d'actions mais qui sont
menées de façon disparate et c'était une
une façon finalement de rassembler et de
voir l'action globale engagée par par le
ministère donc au vu de des réponses qui
nous ont été apportées nous allons
retirer cet amendement
[Musique]
le second niveau de surveillance dit
renforcer est assuré par la Marine
nationale avec sa disposition notamment
des moyens d'inspection de faux défauts
marins à l'aune des récents événements
merbbatiques ayant infecté la
souveraineté énergétique d'autres États
d'autres États nous proposons
d'augmenter les crédits de cette mission
avant afin d'accélérer le lancement de
processus d'acquisition de capacités
matérielles et humaines dans ce domaine
merci
David
je pense que c'est un sujet qu'il faudra
aborder dans le cadre de la LPM et
figure déjà dans la revue stratégique
2022 donc je vous propose un retrait le
ministre mais ma vie monsieur le
président
nous passons au 1267 c'est vous qui avez
la parole aussi
alors par cet amendement je tiens à
alerter sur l'inégalité de traitement
qui frappe les personnels du centre de
transfusion sanguine des armes et à
clama et de l'Institut de recherche
biomédicale des armées à
Brétigny-sur-Orge c'est des sujets que
je vous avais déjà alertés monsieur le
ministre en effet depuis la mise en
application du Ségur de la santé et de
l'instauration d'un complément de
traitement indiciaire correspondant à
189 euros net les personnels du CTS et
de l'IRBA n'en ont jamais vu la couleur
alors que leurs collègues fonctionnaires
militaire agent contractuel et ouvriers
d'établissement industriels de l'État
ont pu en bénéficier à condition qu'ils
exercent dans un hôpital des armées le
CTSA et les rebords restent exclu du
complément du traitement indiciaire et
pourtant ces établissements sont
essentiels au sein de notre service de
santé des armées en effet le CTSA et le
seul producteur de placement
lyophilisés un produit d'une grande
rareté et libre à constitue la pierre
angulaire en matière de recherche
rénovation au sein de notre service de
santé des armées c'est pourquoi à
travers cet amendement je vous propose
chers collègues d'intervenir pour la
revalorisation des personnels du cts1 et
de l'irbain de l'IRBA des 49 points
d'indice qui était prévu par le Ségur
cette mesure permettrait d'établir une
réelle égalité avec leur collègues des
hôpitaux de l'Établissement français du
sang et des établissements
médico-sociaux merci Monsieur
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
Président le ministre
oui bon merci pour votre engagement pour
le service de santé des armées parce que
vous êtes évidemment mobilisé sur ce
sujet alors il est satisfait cet
amendement parce que la première tranche
m'était engagée auprès de vous donc ça y
est la première tranche a été attribuée
au profit de 1365 agents pour un montant
global à hauteur de 700000 euros donc ça
fait globalement 10 points d'indice pour
les soignants éligibles de la médecine
des forces et en 2023 même la sénatrice
la le MTI sera étendue plus largement et
donc là le point que vous avez fait
référence c'est-à-dire le centre de
transmission sanguine des armées
l'Institut de Recherche Médicale des
armées donc là c'est 500.000 euros pour
1717 agents donc là on est sur une
équivalence de 20 points d'indice et
puis après je vous renvoie aux travaux
de la LPM pour l'avenir du SSA de
manière plus globale en tout cas sur cet
amendement spécifique il est satisfait
sur deux exercices budgétaires il est
vrai mais il est satisfait demande de
retrait
et vous avez la parole pour votre
dernière amendement le 1280
alors durant la précédente loi de
programmation militaire le service de
santé des armées a perdu 8% des de ses
effectifs soit 1600 personnelles plus
particulièrement constate le manque de
100 médecins au sein du service de santé
des armées en août se cumulent à cela
des tensions sur les effectifs
hospitaliers dans certaines spécialités
comme la chirurgie la médecine d'urgence
en exercice hospitalier ou encore la
psychiatrie force est de constater que
les spécialités soumises à une réelle
tension correspond à celle où la
concurrence avec le secteur civile et la
plus forte le secteur civil se montre
ainsi plus attractif notamment en
matière de rémunération cela contribue à
une fuite du personnel du SSA et doit
nous conduire et une réflexion quand une
quand tu as une possible revalorisation
rémunératrice de nos personnels
soignants militaires par ailleurs de
cette fuite de ce personnel en quête
d'une meilleure rémunération s'ajoute
ceux qui nous quittent du fait d'un
surmenage en effet puisque le SSR manque
de personnel il a tendance à se projet
ces personnels soignants un taux de
projections supérieur à 100% malgré la
porte de réserviste et jusqu'à 200% pour
les équipes chirurgicales cette sur
sollicitation épuise nos personnels et
rode un peu plus leur fidélisation aux
armées ainsi par cette amendement
d'appel je souhaite engager une réelle
réflexion sur la revalorisation de nos
personnels soignants militaires
notamment par une meilleure rémunération
afin de les fidéliser à nos armées merci
la vie de la Commission celui d'un
amendement d'appel qui intéresse le
ministre dont je lui laisse le soin de
donner son avis mais pour la commission
ces retraits merci une fois plus merci
pour l'engagement pour le SSA bon pour
2023 dans les crédits que vous examinez
ces 39 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour le service Santé armées cette somme
évidemment sera la bienvenue elle n'est
pas neutre bon il est clair que la
prochaine LPM consacrera des moyens
beaucoup plus lourds pour le service de
santé je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
détour un peu les missions du service de
santé qu'on peut appeler à la rescousse
pour beaucoup de missions très
différentes et qui peuvent être en
contradiction avec le maintien en
conditions des forces ça reste avant
tout quand même son cœur de métier des
enjeux se poseront aussi avec
l'augmentation du nombre de réservistes
alors la fois c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'il faut trouver des médecins
réservistes et des soignants en
réservistes là aussi et des réflexions à
voir et compris sur le périmé l'âge des
grades et en même temps sur une
augmentation de manière globale on aura
un besoin plus important aussi pour
faire des visites médicales donc de
toute façon pour plein de raisons on a
besoin d'un service de santé en bonne
santé sans le mauvais jeu de mots
également
sur le terrain de la recherche on voit
bien ce qui a été fait sur les
pathologies du combattant avec les
Américains et avec les Israéliens partie
des trois pays qui avons un savoir-faire
en la matière il faut le conserver il
faut garder une avance y compris sur les
blessures psychologiques ça renvoie
aussi au chantier des maisons Atos bref
il y a tout un paquet de mesure sur
lequel évidemment je vous invite à à
travailler ensemble notamment dans nos
groupes de travail le cas échéant sur
ces sujets pour la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire demande de
retrait le cas échéant ou défavorable
monsieur
si monsieur le Président même si vous
m'avez demandé de faire court parce
qu'il va être 13h monsieur le ministre
vient intervenir en expliquant toute
l'importance je crois que vraiment c'est
il va être retiré cet amendement vu ce
qui est prévu un euro je pense que c'est
vraiment un appel ce ministre lors de
votre premier édition dans la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense du
Sénat vous avez déjà évoqué le service
de santé des armées c'est effectivement
quelque chose de primordial si on veut
envoyer nos soldats et nos militaires en
OPEX je crois que il faut leur garantir
l'hélicoptère qui les évacue les
médecins des soignants mais il faut tout
un service ici derrière vous avez évoqué
les traumatismes et tout ça j'ai eu à
connaître de tout cela et je crois
qu'effectivement c'est une priorité ça
devrait être une des priorités dans la
LPM
oui vous avez bien compris que pour moi
c'était important et et c'est impératif
donc vous c'est un amendement d'appel
donc je vais le retirer merci chers
la commission des finances et favorable
l'adoption je mets aux voix ces crédits
pour
contre
attention
ils sont adoptés je mets au voie
l'article 42 dans ces conditions qui est
pour
contre
abstention ils sont il est adopté mais
chers collègues par lettre reçu de ce
jour le gouvernement
demande à déplacer mercredi du mercredi
14 décembre au jeudi 15 décembre les
conclusions de la CMP sur le projet de
loi de finances 2023 ou la nouvelle
lecture acte est donné de cette demande
en conséquence nous pourrions siéger le
jeudi 15 à 11h ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde
en cas de nouvelle lecture le débat le
délai limite de dépôt des candidatures
seraient fixés au début de la discussion
générale il en est ainsi décidé je vais
suspendre la séance sera reprise à 14h30
pour les commissions actions extérieure
de l'État la séance est suspendue